They're friendly that that's like the biggest compliment ever.
Ready?
Wait,
Neil may all love flash flashlight.
That voice is the voice of Neal Brennan.
If you don't know where we going he be right now.
He was a co creator of the Chappelle show.
Shut up.
Don't [inaudible] on that.
Ladies and gentlemen,
don't hate.
There's a lot to do.
It's just because you can get ahold of a guy on Twitter.
Go.
Yeah,
we know you were the full post,
your Kolbe fucking creator,
whatever you were,
dude.
Yeah.
Next,
next day.
What else did you do?
People don't want to hear that man.
They don't want to hear that.
The actual truth.
Meanwhile,
if it was them,
God damn,
they never stopped talking about.
Yeah.
People look,
if they don't,
if you don't know Neil Brennan,
he deserves to be recognized for what he has accomplished.
I just serve that bitch.
He also deserves a free flashlight.
Would you like one?
Yeah,
I would love one.
I got good one for you.
A fresh new one.
A new package of them were sponsored by the first slide.
There's nothing in that one,
Brian,
because you sucked it out like a fucking Weirdo.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link for the flashlight and entering
the code name,
Rogan,
you will save yourself 15% off on excellent masturbation tool.
It's a real good product.
And Gentlemen,
if it wasn't,
we wouldn't get behind it here at the Joe Rogan experience.
We're also brought to you by on it.
That's o,
n n I t,
makers of Alpha brain,
which is a cognitive enhancing supplement.
If you want to learn all about the various things that we have,
shroom tech,
sport,
shroom,
tech,
immune and five eights the room part shroom is at quarter steps mushroom.
So for one of them,
I don't know what the immune,
the immune one is cause it's not [inaudible].
No,
no,
no.
I thought it was just
selling that you imagined.
How dare you know it's uh,
there's certain mushrooms that they found that people eat in high altitudes to
help them deal with the low air out there and enables your body somehow or
another to process oxygen more effectively.
And it's mixed with other stuff that's really good for you too.
Like it's got a lot of B12 in it.
So together it's a good pre workout supplement.
I take it before Jujitsu or four kettlebells or something like that,
like 45 minutes before I,
I definitely think
it's awesome.
It's the best because it doesn't take a long time.
No,
you can get blasted out.
I'm minutes lasted bro.
Whoa.
You are,
you are.
We're,
we're on it.
We're making kettlebells as well and that should be really soon.
Yeah.
I would like to preorder.
We got,
dude,
I'll get you some.
We got,
uh,
we're going to have regular kettlebells.
We are going to make them the best we can make them and ship them the cheapest
we can ship them and sell them the cheapest we could sound.
That's the goal with that is that,
cause I,
I went and bought,
they're super expensive.
I bought one,
it's like a dollar a pound dog.
Pound's normal.
So 70 pounds,
like a $70 purchase for this one piece of metal.
The Real Bitch,
ladies and gentlemen is shipping these things.
That's where it's going to,
well that's what I went to the valley and bought one.
Yeah like I,
cause I wanted to ship it so we're going to have two different lines kettlebells
and here's what's up.
We're going to have the regular kettle bells that were,
we're going to sell and make as as inexpensive but high quality.
It has to be high quality first.
It has to be done to the right dimensions.
It has to,
the grip has to be the right size.
There's a,
that all has to be taken into account for first and then we have to sell it as
cheap as possible and ship it as cheap as possible.
The idea is to make it as the most,
the mic.
I'm like the most affordable kettle bells that are the best quality you can get.
That's the goal.
That's 100% of the problem says we don't have to advertise anywhere else.
We're going to see like you know,
I think people respond to it.
And have you seen prototypes of them?
I'm like are you already have one?
I'll show you.
They have one here.
Okay.
Cause the line is I I have sweaty palms.
Yeah,
that's good.
Uh,
yeah it is good.
But it sort of slipped.
So that's why I'm saying it's good.
It'd when it's wet I,
I sometimes when I'm,
when I'm concentrating on specific techniques,
I'll chalk up my hands.
I'll use like weight lifted truck.
It really helps.
It stores all the sweat and you just rub it down and chalk it up before each
set.
But when you're sweaty it forces you to grip and harder.
And I think it's really good for your hand strength.
So lately I've been not using the powder and just trying to concentrate on just
gripping and even harder.
And I think I have really sweaty hands,
but I think it actually improves my grip strength.
It's,
you know,
but you also gotta worry,
you throwing a 50 pound kettle bell fucking,
because I do it in my living room.
I have a tiny gym that I lift weights and it's like as small as this office.
So I'll fucking,
if I slip it,
does that happen a lot?
No,
no.
They should not have one of those.
Made my grip a hundred times,
not a hundred times,
but for Jujitsu,
it's made my grip way better than it ever was before because I'm regularly
throwing these 70 pound things around with each hand and there's so much inertia
and there's so much,
like when you're catching it,
you're catching.
This is a fat metal bar with a cannon ball behind it.
That's the point.
Yeah.
It builds your whole body to work as one unit when everybody does,
you know,
if you lift weights,
like lifting weights is great.
If you want to get your biceps bigger,
do curls you want to get.
You know,
it's all simple.
Everybody knows how to do it right,
but when you're doing that normal bodybuilding stuff,
you're isolating all your muscles,
which is really weird and it doesn't ever happen like that in the wild.
You know,
if you're using your body,
you're never in,
you never in a jungle doing like tricep extensions.
It's most people are training for the wild.
Correct.
You're moving around.
Yeah.
The life you're moving around as one unit.
Okay.
And if you want to get strong,
you should get strong.
The idea behind it is as one unit.
So when you're doing kettle bells,
you're whole body is working.
I got to say kettlebells taking my ass from maybe a three and a half to a seven
dads.
So strong.
It says nobody's looking.
I mean you're as a seven,
seven sir.
You walked in front of me.
Okay.
And you sat down and I can't,
unless you're sagging you sagging.
No,
but I hadn't come out thing I had anything.
Nothing white guys at Sag.
I think I was on the door.
I think I was knocking on the door.
You're thinking about doing until I read four hour body.
Ah.
And
then I started doing kettle bells.
That mean,
I mean like sagging your pants.
Oh,
like hip hoppy.
Ah,
I think at this point it's a little corny.
It's ridiculous.
I mean I it didn't bother.
Yeah,
I was probably one of them.
Although I will pry,
I do pride myself on having never really been jived out.
He never drive down.
Not really like the little,
maybe for a second,
like in [inaudible] 92 what was the most embarrassing statement you might've
said in 92 I had a,
I had a public enemy jacket and 92.
Okay.
Which,
you know,
was a little corny and I had a,
uh,
but that was about it.
I mean it wasn't like,
oh,
crazy.
Well,
I probably would have bought a public enemy jacket if they had one by one today.
If it was like now you would,
but this was on there like descent.
Oh,
uh,
I would say that I would say the n word a lot.
Oh,
really?
Just around like my hours are black,
black dude.
Yeah.
Any way was I was,
yeah.
It was like feeling my own white devil.
I've been around those white dudes.
It'll say nigger around a black guy and I'm like,
Yo,
you heard,
what are you doing man?
Do you try and start some shit here?
Like what are you pretending that that's not like inflammatory problem?
Just supposed to let it go.
We're just supposed to let it go because you're cool about it.
Come on.
Silly.
That's a,
that's a highly charged word.
No,
that was my thing.
Yeah.
Anyway,
trucks,
you play on it.
Dot Call.
That was the commercial.
Go check out our shit.
Go Online.
Let's start.
It's going to do something here.
I'm telling you these kettlebells and your ass.
Yeah,
it's amazing workout.
Um,
I love it.
It's the number one strength thing that I do.
Go to [inaudible] Dot Com oh and and it,
and enter in the code name for Rogan.
I think the,
the kettle bells aren't gonna be ready for like a week or so,
but uh,
we'll let you know as soon as they are.
All right.
Freaks.
Let's start this bitch and in the code name Brogan,
get yourself 10% off everything,
every,
all order.
And if you order 30 pills on the first order,
it's 100% money back guarantee.
If you try it,
you don't like it,
you're like,
this is bullshit.
We're way more concerned with no one feeling like they got whipped,
ripped off.
The cool thing is I ordered and they sent like all sorts of little supplement
with it and like it's not,
you don't just get the thing that you got did they send you like the different
stuff,
like like a new mood or something along those lines of tons of like,
hey,
try a few of these and it's called the highest quality shit you can get online.
Google nootropics,
folks,
check in,
look into it.
You know,
don't just make an impulse buy.
You should really read up on it.
There's some fascinating pro and con.
All right,
that's it.
Start the podcast.
Neal Brennan's here,
Ladies and gentlemen.
[inaudible]
Diaz representing.
I'm going to go watch Nick Diaz compete in the grappling match.
Brian,
you want to come and film it?
May 12th in Long Beach.
Nick Diaz is gonna fight up.
Braulio a steamer.
This world champion Brazilian Jujitsu black belt and they're going to have a
grappling only match.
Weird.
Yeah,
that'd be dope.
Hey,
what is powerful?
I've seen you texted me.
Powerful.
It's sort of a catchall silly as awful Neal Brennan,
and so I'm letting you know you're powerful.
I'm giving you energy,
I'm firing you up.
You know I'm,
I'm happy to be around you.
Yeah.
When you say that to someone,
you're happy to be around them.
Powerful Neal Brennan,
right?
Powerful.
Brian Rep Dan.
I don't use it at that much.
I've used the shit out of that text form.
Yeah,
you powerful to me on the spread out that positivity.
That's what it is.
It sounds Corny to say.
Spread out that positive,
sarcastic.
No,
it's being silly.
It's fun.
Powerful,
fun.
Powerful is is like,
it's like,
it's like positive fun.
Can I know like whoever name a guy named,
Gosh,
trying to Taylor Thomas,
powerful.
Jonathan Taylor.
Thomas.
Then kid
don't hate on Jonathan Taylor.
Come on men's at the bomb.
What happens to guys like that?
They go and do lifetime movies now,
does it?
I think he's one of those guys that Pr,
I think I could be completely wrong that he did the school thing where he's
like,
you know what?
I'm going back to school.
I'm doing it for him.
That's the thing to do.
You don't rely on,
there was,
I think the kid from Jerry Maguire got into like a Dui.
Oh yeah,
I had him on podcast recently.
Did he really?
Yeah,
he got a Dui and I remember and like an accident and I remember he was driving a
Saturn and I was like,
come on show business.
Wow.
Do better than give that fucking kid a Saturn.
He was,
he grew up really good.
Like he,
his parents and him are really close and stuff like that.
Now he's like,
does Jujitsu.
He's been doing Jiu Jitsu since he was a kid.
Which kid is this?
Jonathan?
I want to say the lip.
Nikki did.
Frons buddy.
Ron,
did you get to together to,
cause apparently he's good.
He's a real cool guy.
Real Nice Guy.
Really well brought up.
Listen,
some guys get through it.
We had Ricky Schroder on here.
Remember how nice he was.
Yeah,
he's real,
he's evangelical.
He's almost like born again a little bit,
but he's,
he's kind of mellowed off that now.
Um,
they were like pretty hardcore.
Well,
it's his business,
whatever,
but he's,
um,
he's a super nice guy.
He's just in,
somehow or another,
he made it through,
you know,
he made it through as a fucking,
he said he had a weird way of describing it when he was on the podcast.
He said,
he has never not been famous.
She goes,
it's all I've ever known.
He goes,
it's weird and everything,
but it's all I've ever known because I've had some ups and downs and trying to,
you know,
figure out how to deal with it.
But that is,
that's his whole life.
Yeah,
I guess so.
Fuck,
that's nuts.
That's,
so that was a really fascinating conversation.
Being famous.
Do you compare it to not being famous very much anymore?
Um,
meaning like,
do you go like,
fuck,
do you want today to go,
I wish I could just,
I wish it were 1990 I wish I had the identity of 1990 no.
You know how I look at it?
It's just a bunch of people being nice for the most part.
It's like,
what are you putting out there?
How I have opinions about things.
And I joke around about things like the last bad energy that I got was when I
was making fun of some dude in the country music awards but was standing in
front of a jet plane of country music song with jeans that had like cut rips on
them.
Right?
Like on purpose,
like all over them.
And I was like,
come on,
that's,
that's fucking ridiculous.
You were on Twitter.
I couldn't stop goofing on him goofing on those genes.
And then I was even admitted that I wear a fanny pack and I have a wallet chain
and I'm still goofing on that.
Like that's the stupidest fucking jeans were like one day we're going to look
back on those genes.
This is country music,
man.
Country Music is supposed to be Merle haggard,
Johnny Cash.
And that's like real country music.
This is like,
this is not,
that's not real country.
You're standing in front of a judge.
The fuck are you doing in front of a jet?
What are you doing?
Like in a hangar,
like he's playing overseas,
like mirror.
This was like overseas with the boys.
I'm gonna get in front of I suppose troops.
Oh he ain't,
they felt like an f 15 something.
Exactly.
And it's like what?
What are you doing there?
I don't know if the whole show was in front of a jet,
they might've done the whole country moves.
Right.
If it's from a jet,
which would have been awesome.
I don't know if the sets changed,
you know?
I really have no idea.
I only watched it for a little bit,
but it was,
I made a joke that country music awards hates black people so much.
They won't even use black microphones because it was a red microphone.
I was like this last time he saw a red microphone.
Yeah.
That is funny.
Cause I will shit on stuff online and I'm like,
well am I at a certain like we're comics,
but then at a certain point it's like when Bingo I d I don't want to make fun of
that or I don't know.
It's hard man.
Because I always wanted to say what's funny and what I would say amongst my
friends who wouldn't judge me like that,
that we could all be talking like,
like perfect example,
Amy Schumer,
when Amy Schumer's on yesterday and we were talking to her,
we were,
we were joking around about her mother possibly being a cunt.
And I'm like,
how often do you,
you know,
you can just always go there when you're with a bunch of comics,
you're all just sitting around shit on each other.
You could always go to some terrible place and we don't really think you mean
it.
I'm not going to call you on.
We know.
You're just trying to be funny by saying something fucked up.
But that's,
yeah,
that's like with the,
the,
uh,
we talked about the n word last time,
but I was,
I was thinking about how comics,
I was thinking today how my brother Kevin Comedian,
Kevin Brennan and a tell when I was like in high school,
had a joke where if they would like be on the phone and they go like,
hey,
what's the weather like?
And it'd be like terrain.
And that'd be like fucking daggers,
right?
Somehow the black house on fire by remote control,
the weather.
Oh,
stupid and hilarious.
Right?
It was like,
no,
of course you don't mean it.
And also the ID,
you're making fun of the idea that,
but most people just don't,
I sound iron so they just don't get hired and they won't,
they're not able to look at life with layers.
Right.
And they can't see that at the bottom of it.
It's supposed to be about intent,
you know?
And this is,
this is not just about white guys that are throwing nay.
Yeah,
no,
it's just like,
or like you'll just go like what a,
yeah,
you got to know when someone is joking.
When it's obvious there's,
I mean there's certain people,
some people will say things in a crowd and like you'll be the only one that
laughs and there'll be like eight or nine people that are really pissed off.
Come on.
He said something like Gilbert with the,
with the,
with the Geico ads and all the Gilbert's jokes about the tsunami.
We're fucking hilarious.
They were hauling liquor.
That was as he was falling,
I was watching them in real time going like,
boy these are fucking funny jokes.
And then he'd gotten in trouble.
Oh well he went too quick
too quick and you couldn't even do that now you can't do tsunami.
But they,
if you couldn't do it now because people don't remember it.
Did you hear about the Florida Marlins guy who got so mad about days?
It's so ridiculous because I actually,
Twitter definitely like it.
Shouldn't he be protected by the First Amendment?
Tell people the story.
The story was he said that he gave her the space.
First of all,
everything he says is fucking batshit crazy.
He's got one of the funniest Twitter feed licensed Twitter.
What is it again?
How do you spell that?
O z.
Z.
I.
E g.
U.
I.
L.
E.
N but go back like two months cause he just go like,
Hey just GL what?
G U I.
L.
E.
N.
A.
Anyway he said something in an interview where,
and he's great because he just won't apologize for Shit.
So he said something in an interview in Time magazine has been,
you'll,
uh,
that he,
he admired,
um,
Castro.
Now what he was saying was he admired him because the guy I admire Castro in
certain respect,
the fact that Castro has outlasted this many people as a comic,
I'm like,
that's fucking hilarious.
Like this,
the entire world is against this guy.
And he's like,
no,
you can send me exploding cigars.
Nope,
you can fuck it.
I mean,
he's a,
he's tyrannical.
He's a dickhead.
It's,
uh,
but the fact that I respect his endurance,
a guy that can last 60 years.
Yeah.
Like,
and well,
he even,
he even said he's a bad motherfucker.
Oh yeah,
no,
exactly.
The words he used,
he said he's a bad motherfucker,
I think,
you know,
and he's just a lot.
Joey DSOC the same shit.
And Joey Diaz was born in Cuba.
He'll tell you,
it looks at Castro's a bad motherfucker.
I still run and shit down there.
Yeah.
It's like when Bill Maher said that the uh,
tsunami,
he got suspended five games,
the coach of a baseball team for saying that Castro was great or something.
What's a bad motherfucker?
Cause he said that he's been in power for so many years and people tried to
remove him.
He's a bad motherfucker.
It's like he said,
you didn't say like he's doing wonderful things and he's misunderstood and
humanitarian and political strategy.
No,
he just said he's a bad motherfucker.
You're telling me that a guy who's in professional sports can't call a guy who's
a dictator for how long has he been a dictator?
60 years.
You can't call
that guy a bad motherfucker.
Well that's the thing is like you called Gingiss contraband motherfucker.
He can write.
That wouldn't be a problem at all.
You know why gangs Kang is dead.
Right,
exactly.
And also there's not a huge Chinese contingent of Moreland fence.
That's the biggest problem.
That's the biggest problem is that most of the fans of the Marlins are Cuban ex
pat,
or not most,
but a lot of the like
agree with him.
He would,
he what he said wasn't out of line,
but he wasn't in supportive Castro.
He's acknowledging that this guy,
you know,
look at it.
Look,
when people talk about Al Capone,
they don't speak in glowing terms,
but they go to the Al Capone Stories of Chicago are pretty legendary.
Al Capone was a bad motherfucker.
He's obviously an evil person,
you know,
happies dead,
all that good stuff.
Well,
yeah,
that's the thing.
It's like people like Michael Corleone.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
But yet they like stories.
They like theoretical soprano was great.
I love,
they don't like that.
I think is interesting is how far fader he even killed.
He walks by,
people think he's a bad writer.
King Kong stepped on people.
He's a charmer.
He's an antihero.
Fucking you.
One of the groups.
Any error.
Well done.
Hannibal Lecter fucking eight people right at the end of fucking ha.
He got having a little friend to dinner and you're,
I'm having an old friend for dinner and you're like,
you fucking right.
You're going to have it all in front of February.
That is my motherfucker right there.
Yeah.
That fucking awful.
Uh,
uh,
but the,
the question is how far,
like,
so that speech is not protected because I actually twittered like is he not
protected by the first moment?
And they were like,
no,
we only protects you from,
cause I said,
if you criticize Castro in Cuba,
you get punished.
And if you compliment him in America,
Which is like,
so that's freedom.
It's kind of,
uh,
and people were saying,
well,
it's his first amendment right.
It's protected the government,
he can't get arrested for it.
But if you signed a contract,
your company can say whatever they want,
but it's odd because like,
but if you got chance transgender surgery,
they couldn't fire you or suspend you or,
you know what I mean?
Like there's shit that you can do that's protected,
uh,
you if you say gender,
whatever,
if you did something crazy.
I think there's like,
certain things are legal.
There's certain things are protected.
Uh,
if you went to like a,
um,
like if you mark you,
if someone marched for against a fucking getting,
getting her mark marched him or like occupy Wall Street for instance,
they could get fired.
I guess by this logic.
It's like if you say it like Castro and then if you say,
I want to occupy Wall Street,
you could get fired and there's nothing you can do about it,
which is just kind of feels,
well it didn't get fired.
He got some versus spent.
I'm sorry.
Yeah,
but without pay I'm assuming.
Yeah.
I think the idea is that he obviously has an enormous voice as opposed to a
regular guy with a regular job.
And then he's saying is
influential and that they can't show supportive of it because it's,
you know,
it's right.
But what's the difference between that and Lebron and those guys putting their
hood up and releasing that picture?
I think there's a big difference,
but what is it?
Cause I don't know what the difference is.
One is in resistance to what they think is an injustice that was committed by a
guy who's a bit sketchy.
Right.
And you know,
and they want to make sure that someone's brought to justice.
And the other one is a guy expressing his,
you know,
his
[inaudible].
Why I admire one,
I don't understand the connection.
I admire one aspect of that guy's personality is what they're saying.
They're saying he is.
What is what is giving him his props?
I don't even think they're admiring.
No,
I'm saying GN is saying I'm giving,
I admire,
I admire the part of him that was,
has,
has it has lasted this long.
He,
that's the bad mother fucker part.
Yeah.
He's in the fact that he's a pimp.
He's,
uh,
he's done.
He's managed to stay in control as a dictator so long.
You know,
it's,
it's amazing how long when you hear about like a Kim milled young that whatever
his name was,
Kim Jong Il,
the guy who died.
You think about how long that guy and what kind of damage that God in his
fucking regime has done to that poor country.
You're like,
wow,
it's amazing.
But someone can do that.
That that actually can,
you know,
you watch,
you watch game of Thrones or watched that and she'll watch it.
When you think about the idea of kings,
you know,
it's a,
it's amazing that someone is still to this day can rocket king style,
you know,
but there are guys like Castro's rocking it king style.
You can call him whatever you want.
That's the Goddamn King of Cuba.
You know,
you look at Kim jail,
that's the God damn king of North Korea.
I don't care what you want to call him,
president l wonderful l greatness.
You know what did the honorable whatever you want to call them.
That's okay.
I guess my question to the Lebrons and Alpha Male,
I get that,
but I'm saying at what point would Lebron and uh,
the heat get,
where does it cross the line to like,
we can suspend you.
Why would that ever make them be able to suspend,
be suspended?
If they said,
I like cast,
I respect Castro.
He didn't even say anything.
No,
but I'm saying taking a photo,
but I'm saying talk far.
At what point does it become objectionable?
If you say you like Hitler,
a dictator,
Hitler of course,
it's the obvious.
Everybody that's the uh,
when you like you like a dictator or you stand in support of,
um,
a kid that was wearing his hood would,
I mean I'm not,
I'm not making a false equivalency.
I'm just wondering where does one become objectionable?
Uh,
if he had said,
I kind of like,
I think there's so many people that are in support of the Trayvon Martin,
what's his name is [inaudible] Martin,
Trayvon Martin,
and there's George Zimmerman character that they just arrested today.
There's so many people in supportive and investigation into that and there's so
many people that felt like injustice that
occurred and that that kid had gotten killed and it could only have all been
avoided.
There were so many people that would,
it's like becomes the court of public opinion.
Right?
But that's what public opinion is like if we almost live in like a snitch ocracy
where it's like,
ha,
like we're the guy released the KENO video and then we're like,
literally,
you can almost feel people's pleasure when that guy was jerking off on the
sidewalk.
We're like,
fucking,
we got and we got another one.
We fucking weed fucked you up so badly with just scrutiny.
I feel like the light has never been the hotter.
Right?
Like the cultural spotlight of like we're all and it becomes low hanging fruit
to make fun of this guy.
The Coney guy of like fucking,
you didn't have your fucking back strain and Kone.
She's done this for years.
Yes,
but if you even have it in you somewhere that you might get to a point where
you're running around naked,
jerking off in the street,
acting gay as fuck.
I'd like to see that.
Please.
Okay.
And I'm,
I'm happy when some pressure cooker situation out some fucking crazy bitch
because that's what that guy is because you can do that to me all day long
unless you're dosing me up.
I'm not running through the streets jargon off banket that's never come up.
There's never been a day without.
He had been a concern.
That's good.
Think it's like cultural vetting is like,
that is most certainly he failed that he failed life's intelligence test 100% he
failed in several factors.
He felt first of all by making this,
this whole campaign,
which was not quite informed or what wasn't quite accurate with the fact that
like where this guy was the right time and what had been done and what's being
done right now.
And then on top of it there was a huge amount of money that wasn't going to the
actual classics,
some insane amount of money.
And then there was the other dude who was his partner who was joking around
about it and they caught him.
Right video joking around.
There was so many things about it where it just screamed like a brilliant plan.
They put it all sucked.
Did brilliant plan to disguise a moneymaking venue,
a venture rather inside some sort of a charitable organization.
That's what everybody got upset about.
Right.
I feel like there was,
that was uh,
if there,
if it's a football field,
I'm on the 40 yard line of thinking it was basically good.
Do you know what I mean?
Like I thought it was more good than
had.
I think it's certainly generated money that wouldn't have been generated without
it.
And awareness towards that cause you know,
it goes to where do you think it should be?
Should it be a regulation thing or should it be just a court of public opinion?
It's like,
I don't want to compare these two because they're two very different things,
but in a sense it's the same.
Louis C K released a comedy special online for five bucks.
Now that means that no one can release a comedy special for 20 bucks.
You can't do it online because Louie Ck,
who's widely recognized as one of the very best,
if not the best standup working today,
he
said five bucks for his shit.
Right?
So that means it's five bucks for your shit.
And that's how that's,
I think that's a good way to establish it.
Right?
I think that's,
that's a good way.
And it is your way of saying that we're going to start charging for the Joe
Rogan podcast.
I'm seeing the court of public opinion with this guy,
looked at it and said,
okay,
we think it's a good cause to shine the light on someone who definitely did some
terrible shit.
So there's a lot of good in what you did,
but why are you making so much money off that?
That's what the court of public opinion is right about this guy.
And that's where the scrutiny cracked him.
And that's when he ran out naked.
I would venture that no one really gave a fuck about the kids to begin with.
It was like a nice story.
You just go,
yeah.
But meanwhile there's homeless fucking kids outside my window and I'm like,
hey look,
you should move from invisible kids anyway.
Yeah.
I think no one really cared.
I don't think anyone really cared about the plight of the kids cause there's
plenty of,
I think it's like a story that you go,
Hey,
I did you hear the story and then you get in,
you get engaged.
And I so I think that people never really cared.
And then I also think people never really cared that he was making money.
I think.
I think there was a friend to people that truly care about kids' rights and
African issues and shit like that.
And there's a sliver of people that care about,
uh,
transparency in fundraising,
operations.
And then everybody else is just like,
where are we going now?
Fuck him.
Fuck this guy.
Fuck it,
thank did.
This is what happens.
People care.
But they have their own life to deal with.
And that's where it really comes in.
It's,
there's a lot of people that,
yeah,
I care about Africa.
Of course I do.
When I look at this,
this idea that you see these children living in fucking dirt huts and they have
no water,
it was 2000 of the world has been awful.
Shit.
It's terrible.
Of course.
Third of the world's straight up.
Anthony Bordain did some show on Mozambique,
you know,
and he was a traveling through Mozambican.
I'm watching the show.
I'm like,
this is crazy,
man.
They have no running water.
They have no electricity.
They have no nothing.
They have like these grass shacks,
you know,
these,
I mean,
they're essentially living not much differently than people live thousands and
thousands and thousands of years ago.
And they're getting by,
I mean they're having kids and they're,
they're getting enough food to eat and they're keeping the whole process going.
But you're like,
wow,
that's a,
that's amazing.
Then in 2012 that's,
that's going,
I do care.
But then you also have your own,
oh you care.
But it's like what are you going to do and what can I,
it's such a massive problem.
Every,
oh sorry.
I feel like everybody play footsies with Brian.
Um,
I feel like everyone has something that they're compelled to do in this life.
And I think that some people are compelled to charity and I think those people
should do charity.
You know,
I don't,
I don't think it's a selfish thing to pursue your own goals entirely and to only
try to be around and experience of things that you're actually enjoying in this
life.
I think there's people that are
not compelled to do that and they should be allowed to do that and they should
be allowed to pursue charities,
donate money.
And I do,
but I,
you know,
I can't get involved to the point where he eats my life up cause I think it
would,
it would easily,
I could easily get my life eaten up by trying to,
you know,
help kids.
If you helped a bunch of kids and you saw them,
you know,
get over something,
certain illnesses,
you're famine,
whatever.
If you actually were there and experienced it with them and then kept going and
then became friends with them and had some sort of relationship with those kids,
Jesus Christ,
it would could completely consume your life.
He'd be like,
I got to help Africa.
I go to the back.
What's the thing?
That's what the,
apparently the deal was if you love them,
if they became like your little brothers.
Of course,
of course.
I mean the real issue is we need to get her own fucking politicians to do that.
What about,
what do you make of the pressure cooker though?
What do you make of the thing?
Like until like when Zimmerman was gone,
I thought,
oh,
he's going to kill himself.
Yeah.
I'm surprised Jerry Sandusky hasn't killed himself.
Jerry Sandusky.
He's a horrible person to complete scumbag.
There aren't.
So I'm,
these are bad examples.
I think the,
I think people that just get torn,
like celebrities that get TMZ to the point where they just tack camera people.
There's certain,
then you see them,
they just can't take it anymore.
And I don't consider it vetting.
I just consider it.
It's like if the Cultural Tabel ism is so out of control,
I think there's certainly that.
Um,
I think people are also so angry.
They're looking for an enemy.
You know,
people are so angry at the economy.
There's something like 40% of all kids that live between 18 and I think 34
they're living with their parents in their thirties.
They're living with their parents 40%.
That's something that's seems like you haven't
made me cereal.
Mama,
you leave my house.
I just want to clean my house.
My dog for walks silly.
You live in America,
you lucky bitch.
Ah,
yeah.
Mozambique.
Go Watch it.
Watch it.
You won't be such a whiny bitch.
And you're like,
oh well you're lucky.
Speed Internet.
He got that shit like that does as as a grown adult dusting and cleaning the
toilet.
It's such,
it's so Mozambique watch the episodes.
Is that good for you?
You can learn a lots of the Anthony Bourdain show that we were just talking
about.
The one that gets the guy that wears the thumb ring,
he used to,
he tweeted about it.
I tweeted him and Bordain who was the only guy that I've ever met with a thumb
ring that I didn't want to strangle,
but he said I got rid of that shit a long time ago and he wrote a age limit for
that shit and the Hashtag what did,
yeah,
but that's any else that happened?
One that this like tribal things around his belly button or was that somebody
else?
No,
he doesn't have a thing around is he might,
he's got a c minus at the house.
He's got a snake.
Him and his.
Why Anthony Kiedis snake on their arm.
It might be him.
Yeah,
tribal.
Right.
There's something about doing a tattoo around your belly button that makes me go
and have,
like when those dangling piercings,
he'd like little dangling one.
Does any guy ever pulled that off?
No.
No,
but it'd be awesome.
Okay.
Here's what the,
here's my question please.
The,
the question is guy like us again,
I think it's bad that he gets fined.
I think he,
I had,
I think it's ultimately bad for the country.
I just wish people could,
it's,
people are not corporate fucking spokespeople.
Do you know what I mean?
And that's the thing is everyone's become that.
We talked about the Tracy thing last time and everyone's just in a constant
state of a Po.
Anytime you tweet something,
there's like,
wow,
the fuck can you say that?
And it's like,
so yeah,
we were,
you know,
Mike and I,
and,
and I,
you strike me as kind of got it.
It's never going to apologize for anything you said,
I don't think.
Well,
you know,
I'll let people know what my intentions are.
I'm not gonna apologize,
but if I,
I,
you know,
wasn't gonna apologize to people that were mad that I said the guy was a silly
bitch for wearing ripped jeans.
Fake ripped jeans.
That's the,
that's some silly bitch shit.
That's just what it,
what were they and what was their,
their case mad at me like,
oh you get your careers in the toilet.
You need to get attention in this way.
There's a lot of that.
There's a lot of,
they would point out what,
how your careers in this shit or which is most so I get someone needs.
Meanwhile I got more Twitter friends and him.
Hey,
how bout just called Joe Fat.
That works the best.
Fat is a good one.
We were at the comedy store one night.
Some chick w w was on camera.
We caught it on camera check wouldn't stop calling me fat.
Talking about six pack.
He pulls up his shirt.
That hurts.
That hurts though.
Cause you think about Chappelle used to call me fat boy jokingly preposterous.
No,
I know,
but it was next to him.
I technically was had fast and like so it doubled and it gets you a little
crazy.
Fad is a big one for him,
but this was a girl that was trying to make me feel bad and I was like,
this doesn't even make sense.
He owned her so hard.
It was like a scene in the movie was a douchey movie poster.
The villain that's supposed to fill out your six pack.
There's something about showing someone your abs always she stand down or no,
she got robbed.
Yeah,
it turned it into Jello.
What'd she was just like,
yeah,
the kids shred this.
Come on
via.
Yeah,
but do you want,
I just don't,
I don't want people to turn into every,
not every one's running for office.
Just put out good shit man.
Gene.
But then Sam,
you want to make fun of the guy's pants?
Yeah.
You put some of,
I was saying that's the only bad thing that ever get back.
I get that.
Most of the time it's all positive.
You put out good shit and you get good shit back.
You put out good energy.
Good.
You get it back.
I just think it's like,
you know,
mark could be right.
I mean he got fired 10 years ago,
but who bill Maher,
Bill Maher and,
and uh,
even the rush Limbaugh thing,
like rush Limbaugh said,
hey,
piece of shit as far as I'm concerned.
So they just don't listen to them.
But I,
and,
and losing advertisers,
I get,
I guess
it's just,
I dunno know the rush limbo story.
There was a girl who was trying to get the government,
the state,
whoever the fuck pays that insurance that she was getting.
Who has who?
I was Georgetown University.
Okay.
She wanted them to pay for her birth control and rush limbo and it's part of
your health care as part of a healthcare.
And Rush Limbaugh had argued that if our tax dollars were going to go into it,
then we should be able to watch you have sex and you have so much sex.
Yeah.
Like then we should be able to watch that.
Should be basically,
she's a prostitute.
You know,
like you're,
you're having sex for money to bath salts army.
He's a big drunk guy.
Right.
Well he was,
he was doing mad oxies.
Yeah,
to the point where he went deaf.
Alex Jones described to me the process of oxycontin overdose.
It actually makes guys go deaf.
Cause you remember when rush went deaf?
No.
I mean I remember when he was big into oxy,
but oh,
he went deaf.
He went to the point where he,
his show,
it's suffered because he couldn't hear what people were saying to him sometimes
and he could understand that he couldn't hear his own voice so it didn't sound
right.
It sounded off and it went for a long time before he got an operation and then
he got it fixed and they did something.
I think they gave him an inner ear plant.
I think he's got an implant.
God that,
that helps us just foxing going deep.
They said he was up to over 90 a day.
God dammit.
Oh my goodness.
90 fucking pills a day.
Homeboy was cranking though orphan and I was going to have that source,
keep it and get him and shit.
He was getting all kinds of different doctors to hook them up with it.
It gets me.
It gets me now.
Have you done shit like no,
no,
no.
I'm sure it would get you though.
I have no doubt in my mind that the Oxycontin's we'd get me.
I think they get everybody.
I mean,
I think I would be strong that I would get off them,
but I definitely think that if I was hanging around with a bottle of them and a
swollen foot and I took one and then also I'm like,
oh,
this was awesome and then you get hooked.
Really?
No one has anything were really bad to say about it other than me.
Addiction like that.
No one has her hands.
I've heard someone say that made them really nauseous,
but that's what heroin does to a lot of people make some really nauseous.
That's the only thing.
But they say it feels amazing.
Just fucking,
I feel like I get hooked on coke.
We're speed.
I've never even tried coke.
I've barely seen it.
I'd maybe seen it a dozen times.
Whoa.
I just remembered doing kind of crazy ass dream about you buddy.
Whoa,
that's not real coke.
This gentleman.
It's powdered sugar.
We didn't have sugar for coffee,
but not only had I had powdered sugar,
which doesn't really work,
they never,
never goes down.
Yeah,
it's funky.
I had a fucked up dream about you,
dude.
Sweet.
What is it?
You were doing marijuana mixed with math and you were telling me that it's,
the latest thing is kids do,
they smoke marijuana and meth together.
I was like,
what are you talking about?
And you were like,
well,
I would never smoke meth bites and need.
Yeah,
like I would never smoked meth by itself,
but when I mixed them together,
dude,
it's amazing.
And I was like trying to get you to stop smoking,
man.
Wow.
You were hooked on Meth.
Would you say mead need?
What do we be called?
Yeah,
she just made that up.
No.
Yeah.
But I mean that might actually be what it is.
Could you imagine if I started something?
I think many,
I think math would completely overpowered.
I would imagine in women.
It wouldn't be funny though if like somehow another marijuana became a white
knight and your brain fighting off the meth consciousness and you see,
oh,
fucking virtual battle of the positive and negative substances Duking it out in
your head.
It cause if you take like math with mushrooms,
how does that work?
You know what's funny is I had an ex that did,
she was a meth addict before we dated and she's all,
let's tell him about all that stuff.
She's like,
my teeth weren't my for great.
She goes,
my skin never looked better.
Wow.
Like it wasn't bad.
She haven't gotten that deep yet.
Takes a while before your body turns into a fucking Prune Silva.
Some people doesn't tell me.
It'll just fucking,
they turn and it's like,
that'll do it.
She was she a functional math head?
A vague,
I didn't know her.
I think vape.
Not especially she,
here's a,
here's an irony.
She lived,
you know how you always hear about Indians living off of casinos?
She lived on for casino.
Wow.
She was native American seminal.
She lives off the hard rock in uh,
in the one that Anna Nicole died.
Oh Shit.
The one in Fort Lauderdale.
Did you ever play like cowboy and Indian with her?
We would get into some pretty tend it,
share it.
I cut,
I conquered her.
Like I actually get,
I moved in to replace.
Did you gave her a,
gave her a blanket with smallpox on it?
Um,
no we never,
it was actually a good religion.
We were in love.
Joe.
What happened?
She started going to um,
black clubs
to going to cheese,
sort of going to,
she started getting her masters and she started getting her master's in
psychology and at the beginning of the class the teacher was like,
Yo,
just so you know,
none of your relationships are going to last.
Oh Wow.
And she said that she was like,
somebody else broke up today.
Somebody else broke up today.
And then slowly but surely it was like that six months in we were kind of done
cause she was just uncovering stuff about herself and like I didn't,
you know,
she liked women,
she hates men.
Like,
just stuff that was like,
oh,
she's all right women and she hates,
she wanted to date women.
Oh Shit.
By herself.
And uh,
by,
cause I asked if we could do it together.
Bam.
She wanted,
she went,
yeah,
she wanted to date women and she's like,
I fucking hate men.
Oh No,
it's stuck.
Yes.
All of those.
Uh,
if for now,
but that's a mess.
Anybody who says they hate women's a cunt,
you're a guy and you're like,
oh,
women or eight women will get the fuck away from me.
Crazy bitch.
You what?
You hate everyone of a certain gender.
Well guess what?
Same thing if you hate men,
go fuck you dumb bitch.
You think I asked to be born a man?
You know,
just relax.
Not everyone's going to ask for sure.
Being a man's way better,
especially being a manly man.
Cause I mean to be a real Joe Rogan,
you can't get mad at someone for their gender,
you silly ass hole and it's accepted women.
But you're not allowed to sat up case.
Oh,
I've dude,
I've,
I've had conversations with women before that have said,
you know,
men this and men that,
and I'm like,
God damn,
can you give me a chance?
I'm a person,
you know,
everyone's just a person you would throw in me into half the planet.
It's just so ridiculous and did to say that you've got,
I,
if she didn't mean like she hates all men everywhere.
She just,
you could live like I have deep seated mistrust of men.
You could live in a committed relationship.
I mean,
like,
I haven't had any positive,
she hadn't had any positive male deep relationships.
Well,
you know,
how fucking old was she?
How many people had she been around 47 years?
Young?
Uh,
no,
she was,
I don't know if she was 47 years old.
Could have been stuck in some students.
She was in a lot of bad spot.
Therapy's pretty fucked up.
Anyway,
I did it in college.
Same thing.
She was a fucking mess,
like alcoholic,
just crazy.
Always getting in fights with her family and all these other people.
And then she went to the therapy at therapist and every time she would come
back,
she goes,
like,
therapist tells me we need to break up that you're just a really bad person.
And I'm like,
well,
he's probably full of shit.
It tells a really distorted that's not using therapy the right way.
Stupid asshole.
Or you're a bad person.
You could live right.
You could live a thousand lives as a man and still not understand what it would
be to live a life of a woman.
You don't understand it.
You're not a woman.
And as soon as the guy understands that and accepts that,
he'll be way happier when you try to make a woman think like a man.
That shit is impossible.
The same as a man.
Trying to think like a woman.
It's,
and I think both are,
I actually think women are slightly more guilty of trying to get men to think
like women.
We,
yes,
there's more power.
It can.
Yeah.
They can just go like no need to change.
If a guy does that,
he's like a Dick and whatever he guy is in a good,
uh,
relationship that I admire.
The girl's friends hate him
right where it's like,
cause he's such a fucking asshole.
He's happy to do what he wants.
And He,
and it's like,
yeah,
that's you.
He has it.
I used to say to girls,
uh,
I,
you're making me feel like a guest in my own life where,
and that would,
that would get them where they were like,
I understand what you mean now.
Cause it was like,
Yo,
I don't,
I wasn't looking for a coach.
I wasn't looking for like someone,
I need someone to come in and fucking change my taste and change my interest and
change my wardrobe and my diet and just like,
but that's,
but they do,
I think some women,
um,
try to think that that's like a way to go.
Well I think there's also a struggle for power that goes on with people in
relationships.
Everyone,
you know,
thanks there.
They should be the one that decides where we go and what to do.
And some people take that shit more serious than others and some people would
just not very intelligent or emotionally developed.
And so they,
they run on crude tracks and they just fucking bang into each other.
Every time they have relationship,
it's cars just slam into each other and they argue about shit and then they make
up and that's all those stupid fucks live their life.
Yeah.
I think there's a lot of that.
I think that what percentage of people do you think are stupid?
It's a giant number.
Cause I'm in it,
I'm in it and you know,
I mean I,
I always look at how the whole bit,
but I used to do about how people like to think they're smart,
but really we're just buying shit from smart people and memorizing shit that
smart people have really figured out.
This is gigantic body of knowledge and anybody thinks they're smart.
It's dumb.
It's fuck.
Well that's what I was,
I had this argument the other day about it.
Don't you want to live forever to learn everything I do?
Who knows?
You say that,
but what if after this is way better now after this?
Yeah.
You don't know that I don't talk about onsite talking complete nonsense.
I get up,
I go,
I would just sense based on what I did,
there was nothing.
It's good.
I'm going back to where I was,
which is before 73 I don't think any of it ends.
I think it changes.
I think it all becomes something completely different and energy never dies off.
It just moves on to another state.
And I think that the whole cycle of the universe,
we want to think of it as like there was a birth to the universe and it's going
to be an end of the universe.
You know?
That's why they think of the Big Bang,
you know the whole,
there was at one point in time it was smaller than the head of a pin and it was
a giant burst.
I think it's never ending and I think that our ideas of it are all based on her
own biological limitations.
And I think the biological life is a trip.
I think it's an experience.
I think the biological life doesn't necessarily represent what is possible in
reality and I think it's one stage of existence and I think we probably had
other stages of existence.
I think w are what our real true consciousness.
It gets wrapped around language and it gets wrapped around culture and it gets
wrapped around personal experiences and how they interpret them and how they
remember shit that other people have figured out and written down.
But at the end,
in the root of that,
that could take place in a hundred thousand million different forms.
It doesn't have to exist as a human animal making noise with your mouth.
That consciousness could exist in other dimensions.
I consciousness,
whatever the fuck it is that's at the underlying,
the underlying energy that makes the body move in certain directions and choose
to manipulate objects,
whatever the fuck that is at the root of all that could exist as a dolphin,
could exist as a killer whale could exist as a,
you know,
some really smart octopus.
Who the fuck knows?
I think for sure what we are right now is in a evolving species.
It's changing.
It's,
it's,
it's becoming something different.
Look,
man,
I hope you're right.
I like I,
I hope cause I am going to die.
Yes.
Uh,
I just hope there's,
there's an after Paul,
I think we're becoming something different and along the way,
I think whatever the fuck it is that we're,
the human race is going to eventually evolve into,
I think,
I think we're on some sort of a crazy cycle.
That's what I think.
I think we're on some sort of an infinite loop cycle and I think are limited
interpretation of like people dropping off the face of the earth and
disappearing and leaving our lives.
It leads us to believe that this is it.
This is this one thing and this is it.
You breathe in one day your heart will stop beating and then it ends may be
maybe not.
Maybe you're a fucking caterpillar that's becoming,
going to become a butterfly ranger.
I'm Amy or some weird fucking animal that travels dimension to dimension in
completely different forms.
We've seen that happen in physical state,
in life.
We've seen caterpillars and salamanders and all these fucking different things
become a completely different thing.
We've seen them physically met a morph and change.
Why would we,
why would we assume that consciousness couldn't do the exactly the same thing?
Why wouldn't we assume that reality can't do exactly the same thing?
I think it's super possible that were some crazy technological caterpillar and
that we're going to one day press saga,
fucking button,
alright.
And all of our experiences of life and death and love and infatuation and
fascination and appreciation and all those different things are really just,
it's just more motivation for you to keep moving forward and forward and forward
to push this technological machine that society runs on the real,
the real underpinnings,
what's really impacting the universe.
It's not people magazine and Kim Kardashians ass,
but that is there to distract you long enough to keep buying the new droids.
Getting,
the more technology we create and the more minerals we mind and the more we push
the boundaries of what we can do and control in the universe,
the more we get closer to whatever the fuck we're becoming.
Completely locked into an addiction with our cell phones and our computers.
If I'm online,
if I'm like in a hotel and the,
the,
the Internet goes out for an hour.
I fucking,
yeah,
I've been doing,
I started doing a joke the other day about how my phone has completely turned me
into a dick.
I'm a fucking asshole like me.
And as far as like being rude and just fucking like,
fuck you companion.
I'm,
I got everyone else in front of me and I'd rather spend time with them.
I have enough girls pictures on my phone.
I was telling her event that I could publish two months of a magazine.
Girls like send you pictures.
Yeah.
Cause they know you're single.
Ah,
yeah.
But girl,
I mean that's not just like out of nowhere,
it's like girls,
I'm Chen and it's over years.
But I'm saying like,
uh,
like if I told somebody,
if I,
if my phone turned up in the 18 hundreds in a town,
the town elders would burn the town down because they'd be so freaked out by
just the amount of filth on my
phone.
And that's the thing.
It's like you do get hooked having to,
I wanted to bring up,
I went to the,
uh,
the flotation,
I went to float labs.
Yeah.
Me Crash.
I did.
Yeah.
I met crash crashes and interesting individual.
I went a nine days ago and it was a,
it was pretty great.
It,
that's what made me re like my,
my epiphany and I'm sure you don't get epiphany's every time,
but my epiphany laying there was like,
I need to experience some love and I got to get a dog to do that.
Why you said dog?
Ah,
cause I find uh,
work your way up to him.
Yes.
Literally.
That's the,
that's the plant.
Wow.
It's like work my way up.
How fucked up are you?
I'm on a one to 10,
10 being 10 being like you're unfixable.
Oh,
I don't think I'm on fixable.
I think I'm like a six and a half.
Six and a half.
That's still strong.
Oh,
you have a strong,
wow.
I'm new.
Start my love experiences with a dog.
I know it sounds crazy,
but I'm only 37 so you can still pull it together.
It's not too late.
Come from behind champion.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's possible.
I've been lapped by life and I'm going to lap it.
Randy coture didn't have his first fight until he was 34.
So think about,
do want borrow Pekinese uh,
no,
but I feel like that could,
I feel like it could help.
You can totally borrow mine.
Brian's got the most loving dog in the world.
You could try it.
You can borrow it for a little while.
How big is it?
Tiny.
This thing,
I don't like those little dogs.
They all this shivering and if I didn't do that,
it doesn't do,
they seem freaked out.
Freaked out dog.
A guard dog.
It's not scary to you at all.
It's thinking about super affectionate because look at it is,
it's not like a like a dog.
It was like,
oh shit,
a person's here.
You want to make a documentary about it?
Nobody's meaning I love Auger with the dog because look,
I heard Twitter.
It's Twix.
He vixen.
It's a sweet,
it's a sweet dog.
Um,
really one of the nicest dogs on the face of the earth.
But you were never in love.
What was it?
You weren't in love till you met your wife.
Right.
I don't really like to talk about that on the air,
sir.
All right,
fair enough.
This has been a few loves lost along the way.
Got It.
I don't want to bring up any personal experiences that involve other people that
I'm staring at us with.
Yeah.
But look,
um,
yeah,
I've been in love.
But the real,
the real reality of life though is you have to get your own shit together before
you're capable of having any sort of a relationship because relationships will
eventually expose who you really are.
That I agree with.
That is,
you want to talk about vetting that I don't see like we don't deserve someone
who's got their shit together.
If you don't have your shit together.
And that's why it always falls apart.
That's why you wind up treating him like shit.
You don't deserve them.
You know?
You have to come to a state as a human being where all your experiences that you
give to this other person are all like as nice as possible.
You're always,
yeah,
always.
It's complimentary as possible,
as friendly as possible,
as affectionate as possible.
And as soon as you get out of that state,
as soon as you,
you know,
if you,
the only way you can get there is you gotta you gotta really be happy with who
the fuck you are because if you're not happy with who you are and what you're
doing and how you feel about yourself,
and then you start attaching your happiness to this one person.
Like the only time I feel good is when I'm around,
which is crazy.
Like,
bitch,
get your own shit together first.
You can't just be entirely dependent upon one person for your own happiness.
And the only way you can truly be happy in a relationship,
I feel like is if two people can be independent of each other,
still enjoy each other's company.
It's the,
my therapist wants to explain,
it's like concentric circles,
like in the middle is the relationship where you overlap,
but you've got to also be nice to each other.
And that's hard.
I learned.
Yeah,
that's the thing that I learned because I'm from like dumb,
the youngest of 10.
And so it's like in there wasn't at all,
I mean yet,
not my,
yeah.
Yes and no.
Like certain ones like older brothers and sisters did,
but 10 kids is too many.
My mother admitted it and she also admitted that our father didn't love us at
all.
Oh,
okay.
But sounds awful.
Sounds awful.
Is Awful,
but make when when I heard that,
I was like,
thank you.
I fucking knew it.
Do you know what I mean?
I knew he didn't love it.
Yeah.
Wow.
No,
it,
what a Dick.
And so what does he do a box stitches.
He,
he started another family?
Uh,
no,
he's,
uh,
he,
he's actually,
he's like,
he's 80.
He's old.
So he's just hanging out.
You like a whoever talked to him?
We talk sparingly.
Wow.
Uh,
talk to them.
Here's a good example.
Uh,
at my brother in law's funeral,
which was in July,
um,
he,
uh,
my nephew,
my dad's sort of infirmed and my nephew was like trying to help them down the
stairs.
My Dad goes,
don't touch me.
And then he walks the more down the steps and he goes,
if I fall,
it's going to be your fault.
It's just like a crazy guy.
Oh.
Uh,
like a crazy,
angry Irish dude.
Um,
so,
uh,
what,
so what I've found is that,
that you kind of need,
I just feel like I need to rebuild all that shit like,
and,
and what I found with,
all right,
so this is what I was getting at.
Uh,
I was seeing a girl who had to go to the hospital for some like infection thing,
pussy infection.
Let's come on back.
You talking about love and then I'll talk,
you said,
you know,
you said infection thing.
I mean to me again,
I didn't,
I haven't denied but I'm hanging out.
Okay.
Um,
and a Olis man and um,
so she's in a hospital and I was like,
but at this point we kind of weren't seeing each other anymore and she was like,
I'm at the hospital and myself.
And I was like,
you know what,
let me just go.
It was like two 30 in the morning.
I'm like a son.
I was like,
let me just go spend,
like I made a concerted effort to show this person love and what I was,
I felt really good about it.
Meaning it made me fucking feel good to love somebody,
but it's so not my natural disposition.
Well you probably grew up with a bunch of defense mechanisms.
Yeah.
I am a walking defense mechanism that's Chappelle wants to describe me is just
walking through life,
just keeping everyone at a distance,
which I think is a fair description.
Yeah.
I think Matt,
I think we will.
We'll all,
every human that I know has been that state,
at least at one point in their life,
you know you're going to get burned.
You know,
if you get burned,
you're going to,
you know,
not only that you got,
there's no fucking handbook on how to drive relationships.
So you're essentially just get out there and you fucking put the pedal to the
metal and you crash right into the fucking trees,
right?
You don't know how to drive.
You don't know what you're doing.
When you see people and they're dating and they get together and then three days
later they're with each other 24 hours,
his dog,
and they go to the store to buy clothes and they just fuck all day.
Like,
what are you guys really running from?
What's going on here?
This is what they did.
They hit the fucking pedal to the metal,
get a wave,
that car where we were.
That's not the fastest way around the race track.
You know,
the fastest way around the race track is you take every turn with precision.
You watch what the fuck you're doing and you don't go too fast.
But they,
but again,
people don't know what that is cause I actually have the opposite thing where I
take everything with precision to a fault where I'm very like,
no,
I boundaries and you will not sleep over and I will not.
I mean like that's an exaggeration.
But I had that sounds like a lot of fun and the wonder why I haven't upheld
pretty great.
Sounds like a great guy.
If that Indians listening.
Um,
uh,
no,
that was the thing.
It's like she is man,
she would,
she'd think it was fun.
Um,
the,
uh,
but,
but that's the thing is I was very,
because I had,
I didn't understand boundaries,
so I would do the pedal,
the metal thing and then I'd be like,
I got to do the opposite of that.
So I'd be very cautious and I'm not saying there's anything wrong with the pedal
to the metal thing.
Turns out great.
Who knows?
Sometimes it turns out great,
but do you honestly know when it's turned out great?
Do you know anyone where they just fucked for month and it was just fucking,
just physical if you,
yeah,
I know.
Look,
man,
sometimes it works.
I know people that are super happy together.
I've,
I know a few.
It's just you got to get lucky man and well that's the other guy.
He got all fucking get Scott to get lucky.
You've got to get so lucky,
but you also gotta be worthy of that luck.
You know,
you,
you got to have your own shit together to the point where you're fun to be
around the,
you're a nice person.
You actually,
you,
you contribute to the relationship,
right?
It's not like you're sucking off of someone.
Have you ever had a girl that you dated that wouldn't stop fucking complaining
about everything?
No matter why I did it to grow,
it was this,
God is traffic.
Are you driving slow on purpose?
What is going on?
Its car smells.
I smell something.
Yeah.
Was this song who wrote these lyrics?
God,
there's nothing on
this radio.
I think that's a sign of stupidity.
I always say that people are constantly talking about physical sensations.
It's a little bit,
my back hurts.
Yup.
Oh fuck.
Is your hand cold?
Ah,
this fucking smells in here.
But it's also a pattern you get stuck in a negative pattern.
One of the most in my past historic girls of of negativity was she was a smart
girl.
She was,
yeah.
Her whole family who's negative,
they're just cunts fucking snap at each other.
Every everybody just like you over there and meet your thing.
Oh yeah,
I can be around that.
No you can't do that to me cause the other guy we started playing as people with
like do you think I can't go negative t I'm a fucking comic and I can just
fucking,
how dare you tell me to turn it on and I'll do it.
I just don't want to do,
I don't want to be like that.
You just threatened her with your intellect to see how he does that.
Your rocks.
It keeps my friends more way more guys.
I threatened way more guys with it whenever guys.
Yeah,
whenever guys are like,
ah,
why would you threaten?
What do you,
what happens when guys talk all busters when guys are ball busters I go,
look man,
you can bug.
You can keep us from my boss.
And I know you think it's like jovial and jocular and all that shit,
but I'm telling you,
once I go negative,
it's not going to be cute and it's going to be fucking withering and I'll be
relentless about it.
So just stop now because I think guys don't got to way to communicate.
And it's like,
I don't communicate that way.
Like what kind of guys?
Or what are they doing?
You chill.
Um,
now what are they doing?
I mean,
they're just gonna like Nice,
like even that like standup thing of like Nice fucking shirt.
Fheg dude.
Like just,
and it's like,
what is he fucking sweatshirt?
Just when you walk on stage,
I don't know if you go to the comedy club and like comics will,
and it's,
you're not even wearing anything egregious.
You're not wearing cut pants in front of a jet,
right?
You're wearing,
you're not just creating the greatest sin on earth,
which is wearing cut pants in front of a jet is egregious.
Um,
and I'll just go like,
look,
man,
stop.
Like,
warn them.
Yeah.
I'm,
uh,
I'm a big Warner because whenever people like slamming,
it's like,
do you think I can't fucking slam?
I can slam the president in a,
in a fucking clever way.
You think I can't slam you?
Hmm?
You pieces you well,
there's a lot of people that just like to play.
There's a little bit,
but I just think it's,
I think it's founded in a negativity.
I don't think it's,
I don't think anyone means,
so like I've said like how much money when people go,
Joe,
you set for life.
They're not rooting for you to be set for life.
That's,
that's indeed what that semi aggressive,
that's exactly what I mean.
It's like no one wants that for you.
They want to go,
fuck you.
You fucking blew your money,
Bro.
If I were you,
I totally,
and if you're,
if you aren't set for life,
then they're like this,
this Gacaca Joe Room.
You have nice eyes,
lashes.
Thanks a lot.
So thank you very much.
Is that what you like?
Long Island?
Just notice it.
He has really prominent eyelash.
Thanks a lot man.
He gets mad.
So I'm going to go positive on you if you're not careful.
Careful dude.
He'll just fucking columnists were a lot.
Got It.
Yes.
You look like a skinny George Zimmerman.
How about that?
So what do you think about this thing now that they grabbed the Zimmerman?
Dude,
you think it's going to calm everybody down?
Uh,
yeah.
I uh,
I think,
yeah.
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't think so.
I don't think that they,
they,
yeah,
but I don't think they were going to bring a trial because people want one.
I think the woman,
the prosecutor was like looked at the,
I think the local PD was awful.
I mean,
there were Shitty,
even the way they walked him in where they walked him in,
like he was a cop.
Like,
Hey,
you want to go ahead?
One of them walks around them so that he's behind all of the cops.
It's like,
is that how you treat suspects as you fucking just walk them in?
They're not pushing them.
Then I like hearing them fucking,
yeah.
Jason stayed them Dole.
Those [inaudible]
kills all of them.
It's all on tape.
That'd be fun.
You don't know that he's not transporter.
Imagine,
remember.
Yeah.
Remember transporter.
I still,
I always thought you should have movies like that.
I don't want to do those.
You said that last time.
Thank you.
I've always taught,
I've always uh,
I even killed a meeting once.
I had a meeting with these people about a martial arts type thing and I said I
don't want to do anything that looks for dare to us.
I go,
I don't want to,
I would never fight a retard wagon train where there's 10 [inaudible] you can
say all their,
cause everybody was really crazy.
I did with zookeeper that scheduling conflict
fun.
I'll do it.
Kids movie in a heartbeat that look to a martial arts movie.
Man.
I know I would not want to do a movie where I run the observation that when
you're in those movies they don't work cause everyone waits to fight.
There'll be eight years and they'll wait one at a time to get their ass beat.
That's ridiculous.
And it just all jumping.
You go to Worldstar hip hop.
Okay.
You want to find out,
go to Worldstar hip hop.com and you deal.
We'll see a lot of evidence how people fight.
This is what happens.
You get punched in the face,
you've gone unconscious,
your head bounces off,
the concrete,
people proceed to kick you and then they take your clothes off.
That's,
that's a real fight.
Stupid.
Yeah.
All right.
That's what people should say.
This is nonsense about one guy waiting into a crowd of folks and just fucking
annihilated.
Pavel.
Respect to stance.
If you're going to dance,
people were like,
Hey,
one of the time,
Patrick Swayze eyebrow cut.
We're just dribbles a little bit by the face.
Was it the last ice house critical is that we were talking about this where like
the worst is when they get knocked out and then they,
they're still punching and co
like a rag doll head.
Her [inaudible].
Oh,
but like actual street.
Did you see the lights of the ball?
Just a couple of why watched a little bit of it.
It's horrible noises.
Head made when it hits the concrete because it's like,
no,
but it was hollow because his mouth was open a little bit like a Pumpkin.
He got caught.
He got hit by the world.
It's like,
that's what it's like.
It's like the world at 20
miles an hour.
It's ridiculous.
Have you ever broken up something like that?
No.
Yeah.
I'd like to think I would,
but there's a part of it.
It's like,
I think I would just go like,
yeah,
be careful.
Do you?
You,
you,
you could get jumped and taken right into that.
The first most important thing is it was not a lot of people.
The most important thing is to get the fuck out of here and call the police.
That's what the most important thing is.
If you want to jump in,
if there's,
I mean,
how many people are there?
10 15 people and you don't think someone's going to sucker punch you too.
They just sucker punched this dude and putting them out.
You ready to go?
Scrap with 10 people?
How confident are you?
Stupid.
You know?
I mean,
even if you get in there and try to,
to saving and say,
hey listen,
this is a,
this is fuck crazy.
Leave him alone.
I mean,
you,
you've got to gauge the situation,
gauge how they respond to it.
You better be ready to run for your fucking life.
That's some real shit.
You know,
the people that are good people have to understand that there's not,
the whole world is not populated by good people.
Right.
There's a lot of people out there that our mother fuckers,
and they'll do crazy shit to you.
Well,
it's also interesting how quickly it just becomes like,
and a mob.
Yeah.
Like just fucking something in the brain just goes,
if you are white and they're black,
and in that situation,
that was clearly,
they crack that dude.
And then you,
you hear them deciding altogether to just rob him and take his shit.
And if you tried jumping into that man that you were your,
with that guy,
you're going to be with that guy.
Even if you just protest what they're doing.
It's not like you're a pro.
What if I say,
look guys,
I cocreated Chappelle shall be reasonable about this.
I have some DVDs,
not on me,
but I can give you all give me your mailing address.
Then they just start fucking you.
Yeah.
I mean that's
actually fucking actually fucking that.
They'd be like,
listen,
we got to take this opportunity to fuck,
but that's the,
you know what's funny is that's the interesting thing about the same part of
people that just goes,
and mob is the same part of people that go and comedy club laughing.
It's the same to me.
It's the same mechanism.
What?
It's the same.
It's just your brain decides we're laughing and that's funny and I'm going to
attack.
I think it's the limbic system,
I think,
and you just go on and go,
yeah,
but laugh.
I don't know.
I don't,
again,
I understand that's based on just going straight wild crazy.
But you know what I mean about when he'll do a joke that,
and someone in the crowd is,
you have like a pocket of dissenters.
They make the show worse for everyone around them.
Right,
right.
And they don't do anything.
They're just,
they have energy.
I just think it's like some human energy shit.
I think it's like some animalistic humanity.
I did live audiences,
man,
we've all experienced that where someone is sitting in the front and they
looking at you funny and they cross their arms and you'll even say,
I'm like seeing the shaking their head like got to funnel for me.
I've seen some that people will do that until like fuck with you.
It's like like the people that would stand in front of you if you were playing
pool and they stand in front your shot and like make faces kind of shark you.
That's exactly what they would do at a comic club.
Like when you do,
you watch basketball and dudes are in front of the mat and they're doing that
thing.
It's guys do that all the time.
There's people that,
people that are always going to want to see if they can fuck with you.
Especially if they,
I think it's awesome.
They haven't been a comedy clubs many times cause I think a lot of people go to
come to come.
He's like,
all right,
we better make me laugh cause I paid money.
It's kind of like a,
almost like a job.
It's just that,
that Billy Wilder,
the director said that,
that uh,
audience members are individually,
they're idiots,
but together they're a genius.
Meaning the collective unconscious thing.
Like,
like if,
if I,
I do a joke where I say,
uh,
I'm Vegan,
it's easy to be Vegan in la,
but the rest of the country mountains walk minus will walk up to people and go,
hey,
where do faggots eat?
Okay,
simple joke.
Funny.
Basically a knock,
knock joke about,
now I'm the,
I'm not being homophobic,
I'm not doing anything.
Most of the time they're laughing before they can go,
hey,
wait a minute.
That's kind of,
he said Faggot.
That's kind of homophobic.
How do I feel about that?
And that's what all of comedy is kind of like that.
And it's,
and I believe it's the same thing with a lynch mob where it's just like,
and were a mob before they go.
Maybe a guy that we just punched out,
maybe we don't take his pants like they're just doing it.
I don't think that was the case.
I think he was around a bunch of criminals.
Oh,
you think so?
Fuck yeah.
Yeah.
There's a Shitload of criminals in Baltimore.
Crime in Baltimore.
Baltimore's through the phone.
Yeah,
I agree.
No,
that was a drunk guy who was out with a bunch of criminals and they decided to
beat the fuck out of them and steal shit from him.
And that wasn't the first time they made the fuck out of somebody.
That was the first,
it wasn't the first time they stole shit from me.
That's the,
that's what that was.
I,
I don't,
you know,
I don't think it's anything but that it's real simple.
I think it probably,
maybe two of them were criminals and eight of them were like got in on a moment.
We got dark pockets of humanity and that guy was strolling drunk through a dark
pocket of humanity and they fuck,
they fucked up.
What I would say is there's dark pockets in every single human.
Yes,
it's possible.
But you have to have the certain combination of neglect and abuse as a child and
abuse by your environment.
And Abuse.
You have to have a certain amount of disconnect with the idea of community and,
and brothership and fellowship and love.
You have to have enough fucked up shit in your life that you don't go the
natural way.
Humans that are raised with love and humans that are raised,
you know,
in a good community,
that's,
that's what they,
they try to appreciate and cultivate.
And when you're not and you lash out,
I mean,
it's a,
it's almost always because somebody did a fucking terrible job of raising some
kid.
Oh yeah.
I've been some other place where everybody around was terrible for kids and
these toxic access pools,
occasionally they shit out excellence.
You know,
when someone will just,
would try so hard to get away from it.
They become this,
you know,
mega mogul type character or you know,
some super rapper dude.
I mean in or a fighter or an athlete or something like that.
But I mean,
essentially that's,
that's uh,
it's a dark,
horrible pocket of humanity where anything could go wrong.
And that's one of the main,
if you want to cry racism in this country,
the real reality that that's some of the most racist shit I think.
I think system when,
yeah,
when you see,
when you see a problem area like that and you just dismiss it as a bunch of lazy
people,
you're dismissing babies,
man,
you're dismissing them.
That is clearly in a way it's either dishonest or it's racist.
It's one of the other,
because you are ignoring the fact that these bundles of potential human beings
are being brought into this fucked up situation and instead you want to
concentrate on some minerals on the other side of the world or some Taliban
dudes that may or may not even exist.
You know?
I mean how many,
how many of them are there really are,
we are 300 of them.
Isn't there just a bunch of fucking people where you're in their yard and they
have put Joe,
they have over 200 horses and and he spearheaded pickup truck at least appears
they have.
They ate at last coming of eight sphere.
Fuck man.
And just think about all the potential that could be saved if we put the
resources that we're putting into going to these other countries.
That giant fuck,
well that's the thing.
Yeah.
It's like tape,
like Bill Gates,
ending malaria at that money and took all those people and hired them.
Instead of giving them jobs as soldiers,
giving them,
give them jobs as community rebuilders provide the same kind of jobs that could
be available to a million soldiers,
could easily be better spent in this country to having community builders have a
million fucking people that you send throughout the terrible spots in this
country and they rebuild the infrastructure of community centers.
They set up afterschool things for kids and mentoring for kids that get kids
around,
people who can be good role models and they teach them better than they're
getting in these fucked up schools where you might as well be going to prison or
do you believe in the idea of like welfare queens,
meaning women that live exhibits but,
but I don't see,
but to me it says it's a spectrum of humanity,
man.
Yeah,
no,
I agree mom.
At all.
About,
but I think that that's how people that are against what you're saying.
No.
Here's the problem with people that are babies don't deserve to be fucked over.
That's the real problem is that we are not taking into account the babies were,
we're putting one of the most difficult tasks to the world and we're taking
someone who can't even take care of themselves and we're helping them take care
of themselves so that they can keep raising this baby in the most fucked up way
possible.
Right.
When really what we should do is try to educate them and try to come in and help
them and try to figure out what the fuck can be done to put this person in some
sort of a positive state.
So just so somehow or another you can raise this baby,
right?
That,
that,
that person's done.
That person's,
yeah,
she's 45 and she's been on welfare whole life and she's addicted to crack.
She's done.
You can try and help her if you want,
but you can say that baby.
Well,
that's what I that don't even saint some ways like do you want,
I almost see is like
a buyout of people.
Like you're going to be a terrible cvs employee,
so you're going to be a drag on the economy.
We're going to buy you out,
we're going to pay you to stay home basically and just make 240 bucks a week and
we'll give you milk and sugar and all the shit you need to eat.
But we don't,
you're not good for the economy.
You're all,
you're just bad.
It's worse.
But I also think that another,
another thing that when people on the,
generally on the right say that there's all these welfare queens and stuff,
it's like,
you know,
and they got so many babies,
you know what would help them not have babies?
Birth control.
It was,
you gave them some fucking birth control.
Yeah.
But even if you do that,
there's going to be some people that I know.
I'm not saying nobody's going to have babies.
I'm saying they,
it's the,
it's like the,
well,
you had the baby,
now you got to do it.
It's like if you gave her rubbers or if you gave her,
uh,
the pill,
you'd have less babies who we have to figure out a way to make our community
somehow or another,
our,
our existence here,
at least in this country.
I mean,
we can't control the whole world,
but I think in this country we're capable of getting to a place where we w we
have accepted things and standards for our communities and if we just
concentrated the amount of effort we spend on military shit,
on trying to figure out how to stop kids from growing up,
fucked up,
how to come in and help him,
how to,
how to come in and catch them while they're young,
while they're not a mess yet.
That's the,
that's really,
it'd be no one is looking at that.
They're allowing all the multiple autistics and they just allow nature to run
its course.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
And then it's like you,
you a big kicked someone in the Shin and they'd go,
what are you limping for?
It's like they're born into this terrible thing and then you go,
you're fucking lazy.
No,
they're born into this.
They,
even if they weren't lazy,
they,
they're in such a shitty system that you have to be 10 times more motivated to
get out of it.
It's,
I've been around a lot of dudes,
especially when I was really young that the grew up in the projects and then had
like a lot of the kids that I used to do martial arts tournaments with,
they came from really fucked up place and it was super depressing sometimes when
I'd go to visit them and go to where they,
where they lived and they had a lot of anger inside because of that.
There was a lot of like frustration because of that nade got out of it with
martial arts and they become productive members of society.
But when they would tell me some of the stories of this shit,
they had to go through bad.
The crime is and their projects and how scary it is.
You can't have anything sticking out of your pockets.
I'll rip your pockets open.
Yeah.
Like whoa man.
And then the week before they've even gotten to white people.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Like that's before that.
That's the,
yeah,
we,
I got a podcast called the champs.
It's on Itunes,
good,
whatever.
And uh,
we only have,
uh,
we,
we only have a,
we only have black ass on cause I've just never had a boring conversation with a
black dude.
We've had an Jose Conseco and bought ever had a boring conversation with a blog.
Almost never.
Almost,
no,
I'm not saying never.
But I find that more of conversation with black dudes
are interesting and uh,
inspiring and,
and uh,
and just fucking engaging then.
Then why I know if you'd do is you'd walk away from No.
Yeah,
of course there's a few,
I'm sure there's exceptions.
I'll get a few do as a child a quarter and change that statistic.
But that's the thing is white people,
like they don't spend any,
the thing that I always say is it's important that most of black dudes,
I know that like did something with their lives,
spent time with white people at a young age because it's important to get
demystified.
Demas have white people demystified.
You Go,
oh,
it's not,
they're not all out together either.
Not all white devil.
Yeah,
they're not,
they're just living their life.
They're not,
uh,
they're also not these big Paul Bunyan ask fucking,
they're not these phantoms that control everything and that they're just people
they're trying to live like I am.
And vice versa.
It's good for white people to hang out with white people,
but the amount of just shit the average black dude has to deal with on a regular
basis,
just,
just as part of the culture.
It's just like,
ugh.
So discussing like Lowell Shinar calves and just every single interaction
banging some hot,
real hot blonde white girl.
Oh,
forget it,
Joe.
Yeah.
We actually talked about this yesterday with Amy Schumer where she was talking
about how many of black girls have that,
you know,
anger at black men for not dating a black girl like mad.
And I'm like,
that's like one of the few,
like blatantly open pieces of racism we allow,
you know,
that's,
that's like as racist as he can get.
You shouldn't be dating white girls.
Well,
no,
no.
It's crazy.
It's like we need to,
we're all the same and we need to overcome about how fucking dare you.
I've always error you.
Like we're not all the same.
Like it turned out we're not all the same.
These bitches are evil and you got yourself to worry about and where the human
race and if you fall in love with a Filipino lady,
it's nothing wrong with that.
All right.
You know,
and just because your girlfriend.
Yeah,
it's nonsense.
Who the fuck is anybody to tell anybody who did date?
Well,
generally the,
generally the problem is white.
Black girls don't like white dude.
Whereas black dudes,
white girl,
tough shit.
No,
I know a lot of open yourself up to more shit.
How do you think Chinese dudes feel if they only like white?
They got a hard ride.
They got to feel real hard to get a white chick.
If you're Chinese,
dude,
yeah,
I do a job and a lot of them pull it off.
Don't get me wrong.
It's not a,
it's not a common thing.
Yeah.
I do a joke where I say,
uh,
I'd say I used to ask people that were mixed.
They were half white and half Asian,
which parent is white race.
But it's a stupid question because I realize that the dad was never Asian
fucking ever.
That's not true.
I,
it's not,
you'll find one person,
but mostly it's like I met her when I was in Korea.
There's always like this,
the uh,
well cause also white girls don't like Asian dudes cause white goes,
don't like,
cause they don't like short dudes.
But what if is a big one?
There's,
I know a lot of guys,
I know there's some sec.
You've got to be a sexy fucking Asian to get white girls.
You gotta be a Bruce Lee.
You've got to be a fucking,
uh,
Kevin Shay.
He got me a,
a,
a Bobby leak and Jong Kim.
I mean,
you gotta be,
you gotta be a Jeremy Lin.
You gotta be as sexy fucking Asian.
That's wild,
isn't it?
Yes.
It's probably the hardest road for White Pussy,
right?
Asian.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
yeah.
I was going to say Mexican dude.
What's the hardest?
What is it?
What is it was the hardest?
If you want to get a black check,
Asian guys.
Well,
Hey,
probably Asian guy and some guys.
Wow.
Right?
Yeah.
Could you see Beyonce going out with a,
an Asian guy?
Could you ever see that?
Sure could not even.
Sure.
Good.
And Joe sure could.
Yeah.
Might even be a clean slate.
But Bruce Lee,
I fucking,
you gotta be bad.
Had happened.
Some weird place like Scottsdale,
Arizona or something.
It's hilarious.
Tanning Salon.
So they're just both a little off and she gets a thrill out of the fact she
hangs out with this dude who speaks Mandarin.
Yeah.
Maybe.
Maybe her dad was like,
really in a Kung Fu.
Yeah.
There's what again,
it's gotta be like,
Shit.
Yeah.
But I would have said I don't,
yeah,
it sucks.
It's just one of those things.
It's just like,
man,
there's nothing we can do about it.
Yeah.
It's just history.
Although having said that,
I've met during gangs,
cons,
time to bring it back to that,
that they Asian dudes could get posted because it,
first of all because they were taking it,
but also because they,
that was the paradigm of masculinity.
That's interesting.
That's fun.
That's really fascinating.
So what happened that,
that,
that change,
what is it all cold?
That's why I always find that when I go to Europe,
it's odd that in America it's,
take it to me it's like a,
granted that black dudes are cool and create a lot of culture.
And in Europe it's kind of like no soccer.
The number one sport they prefer like techno music to hip hop.
Yeah.
There's a lot of like,
so there's no,
they like don't even get like black fashion isn't a thing.
They all wear tight pants.
Like whereas here there's a huge strain of black cultural dominance that you go
to the urban,
it's just,
it just fucking evaporates.
Um,
but I think it is that like what's the,
what,
what do people conditioned to think is good?
Yeah.
Really?
Well.
Why by sexually?
That doesn't make sense to me because sexually to me it's,
it's always clear with what men like men like the same thing,
every God damn turn and there's a few Weirdos and want stick figures and fat
women men.
What's the magic ratio of the two to one hips to waste?
Much of it is,
it's natural and ratio.
It was a lady that I was,
I was in Beverly Hills today and there was this lady and she was probably in her
forties deep door forties which I try to be respectful and not have like ugly
feelings about women who were older than me.
When I look at her,
she was
so nice.
She had these like thin,
she had this thin waist in this house.
You could tell this bitch goes to the gym.
You could tell she worked out hard.
Like she was like really well kept and you just look,
just
look at her body like instantly or wow.
Like that sex.
Like that's what she looks like.
Sadness.
You're built for sex.
She looks like sex.
Yeah.
And that's,
that's,
that's just like,
but again,
like tall guys saw the shoulders that I'm talking to in general.
They like,
do you know what they like?
They like strength.
They're like,
yeah,
this is a gold genetic strength.
Yes.
And they also like social worth.
They liked frank strength is absolutely,
that's monetary strength.
They want,
they want whatever it looks attractive to mate.
It's the same thing that men want a woman that can fucking protect their baby in
utero.
And then why,
why not Asian?
Because they're not tall and they don't have,
generally speaking not to all.
And they don't have broad shoulders,
but shots.
Yeah,
they do social skills.
So it is,
no,
it can be smaller.
Second,
well way it just there.
I don't know.
They're just like any of the agents that I know,
they're,
they're very,
they're very foreign.
Like,
like,
like when it comes to just calming,
you know,
pop culture,
pop anything or these are you talking about American,
Asian American agents that I know that we're having conversations with them.
It's very different than having like a conversation with like,
uh,
an Asian chick.
Do you think that it's because they came from the parents of immigrants and
their parents were like super strict that there's a little of that.
I mean you're,
you're making a big generalization obviously.
I knew a lot of just talking about the people I know Bobby Lee,
he's taught like that.
Bobby Lee's pretty cool.
Right?
You know,
there's a lot of Asians that are like totally down and cool.
I know several of them
I know more than are actually cool and I like that are,
you know,
a lot of fats but cool that girls would want to date him.
Cool though.
Or more like,
hey,
they're cool if I went and talk about video games and stuff.
Cool.
If I wanted to just hang out with them.
I know when I think about the dudes that I know that are Asian,
I know a lot of girls arts guys.
I know a lot of Asians,
boots from martial arts.
I,
and I know a lot of them.
If I want to talk about the most percentage of Asian dudes with white
girlfriends,
it's usually martial arts.
That makes complete sense.
It's a show.
It's a fun there.
Peacocking there and they're fit.
And they were Bruce Lee Brown sweatsuits over where they go and sit for a six
pack penis,
which is easy to get in her mouth.
And it's like there's no real easy super and he's happy about it and he doesn't
care.
It feels good for him.
Uh,
yeah,
it was really just getting her pussy eating anyway.
I mean surely doesn't even like sex that much.
Yeah.
So them works stereotypes aside.
But I think I have a friend that was,
um,
she was raised by a very strict father to the point where when she got older,
like all of her boyfriends became,
uh,
she wouldn't date Asian guys.
It was all white guys,
only white guys.
And um,
her father was like,
I just guess just such a like stereotypical over the top,
like,
you know,
authoritarian,
like really strict Asian father and it just completely whacked around to the
idea of ever dating an Asian guy.
And if that's the case,
if it's like,
that's a part of their culture.
Like I know like my friends are Korean.
Like I had a buddy who was Korean.
I have never met anybody who worked harder in my life.
That's the thing.
There's not,
there's no machismo about the culture.
It's just basically like quiet hard work.
Oh my God.
Yeah they did.
They're not in a bragging at all in chains or not ended up showing getting nice
cars just like we're planning for the next generation.
My friend,
junk sick,
John Chang,
we did taekwondo together.
He went up on the national team.
He was a national champion and he was in fucking medical school and he took a
little bit of time off from medical school to to,
to compete.
Never met a guy.
Works out hard vacuum.
Good example.
Yeah,
the just fucking or some shit.
And he's the Gulf
of Thailand develop aids
and he lives in the fucking,
the place by the Beverly center with eight of his cousins of does he really
know?
Like when they come for fights they stay at the Palazzo,
Hey,
what you doing?
Why would you say they show it on the they cause they show it on that show.
Oh that's so stupid.
And there's a gate.
Why would they do that?
How many would nutty people are waiting outside for him every day and fight him
to fight them.
They'll go ahead and go ahead and they go to the,
he goes to wildcard jam.
They know where he goes.
That's the kind of thing when you're that kind of bad ass,
it's like,
all right to go,
what are you going to do?
We filmed him,
I went there for Tasha show and Tasha was gonna let Manny Pacquiao punched him
in the head.
And uh,
I was as corner man.
you know,
he really hit him.
Really?
He was very nice about it.
Like you,
the first couple of times he hit him,
he like barely hit him.
Right.
And then we're going to say gingerly,
no,
I was searching for a word,
but generally would apply.
That's a good word.
Um,
but the,
the amount of people that were there,
it was insane.
The amount of people there,
there,
there is a Tasha show.
They were there because that's where Manny Pacquiao train.
And I mean this was I guess like a year ago,
maybe less than a year ago.
Maybe less than two year program.
Um,
and so he's only gotten even more popular since then.
I mean he's got damn superhero.
Yeah.
There's a restaurant,
a Thai restaurant that you eat at downstairs.
It's got all pictures of him on the wall because that's where he eats.
They know it or yeah,
you can find many package.
Yeah,
you can find them.
What are you going to,
so that's the end.
He's a humble dude.
Oh,
he's the nicest guy ever.
He's a sweetheart.
Uh,
that is that weird thing that fighters have where it's that that you're like,
where you don't really brag.
Well,
I think when you get to be the point of Manny Pacquiao,
why would he brag?
I mean that guy probably can't believe.
How do you make of his life as well?
That's sort of part of it is his shtick.
And it's also
a part of it is why he's become so successful.
And it's also part of it,
it's his environment.
And if you look at it,
I mean there's no better example than those shows,
those HBO series when they follow him,
because if you follow his life,
man,
his father was in jail.
Okay?
His father talks mad shit to them.
They talk mad shit to act like he's,
he's saying to his father,
he goes,
you ain't nothing.
You ain't never nothing.
You Ain't,
you ain't no champion who never know champion.
And he says it to his father's face on camera and you know,
he shuts down his father.
It makes them look like shit on camera.
And then as you know,
his is his uncle Rogers the same way and they just talk mad shit to each other.
And Roger just kind of,
he's a on trial for domestic abuse.
He beat some girl loving that.
That's the environment.
And then Floyd smack some girl and you know,
he's got to go to jail for 90 days.
Then letting them fight first.
You know,
I mean it's really,
that's a crazy life.
He's that,
that's part of his environment.
But look how goddamn discipline that dude is.
Floyd will get up,
he'll go out clubbing,
drinking water,
and then with his jeans on,
he'll run like one 30 in the morning just to say it gets his truck to draw his
driver,
whoever the fuck he's got working for him to drive the car behind him and he'll
just go run home.
Do you think that's characterological meaning,
do you think it's just in him meaning edit certain point?
It's like that So-and-so's disciplined.
It's almost like they're not,
they're just there.
It's just how their brain is like,
they're just like Floyd.
It's not even,
it's like I just got to fucking wrong.
No,
no,
he's not that crazy.
I think he's doing the work.
I think he's just addicted to success and I think he knows exactly what he has
to do to be as good as he is,
which is better than almost anybody.
And I think his technical skill is only only a eclipse by his work ethic.
And that's what people don't understand.
He's got great technical skill.
He's a great boxer.
He doesn't ever seen him fight live.
Oh yeah,
he's,
he's on a different speed.
Yeah,
he's,
well,
he's also so accurate and it's timing is fucking genius and he knows how to
control a fight and he knows how to pace himself.
He knows how to do anything.
But one of the big things about that dude is he never gets tired.
That guys never even remotely tired.
You never even see him slow down.
You know he's,
he's never in a war where he has to dig down deep because someone's been rocking
him.
Know when he starts seeing fighters in those fights,
they're covering up,
bouncing off the ropes.
The last time you saw that flow back
guy that he ended up knocking out when the guy put his hands down,
[inaudible] was giving them a lot.
No,
no he wasn't.
He wasn't hitting him with shit all he was hitting him with.
It was headbutts.
That guy was,
oh,
I agree.
He throws a lot of punches.
But Floyd is a goddamn expert at moving with punches and about sliding away from
punch.
The only guy ever hit him clean that I've ever seen in a modern fight.
Not when he was younger,
when he's first starting out.
But in a recent fight,
it sugar Shane Mosley caught him with a right hand or rock done.
But you know,
you guys fucking calms himself down.
Puts a song.
Nope.
Nope buddy or rock.
He got cracked.
I like that.
That counts as like he got to hit those guys get knocked out.
We're the one time he got hit,
they all get hit.
But he got hit right.
No I get in the pool.
But that's how fast he is is that you're bringing up like in one time in 1998 a
guy actually landed a punch clean.
Exactly.
I saw him fight Hatton and somebody else and you just got like,
this isn't even a,
they're not even in the same way.
He's way too good for them.
He's way too good and hadn't started getting tired.
I mean it hadn't was a tough guy but high and was also a partier.
Fuck hat.
And after he got out of the game,
he got real big.
I started doing cocaine.
Got Call with it.
Yeah.
So which is so sad when he see fighters that like they get out of the game and
then they just,
they don't know what the fuck to do and they go crazy.
It happened at Joe Louis,
it happened to,
you know Sonny Liston and habit to a lot of them they don't want to do is just
get fucking nutty there.
What a wild ride they'd been on their whole life.
Then all of sudden you say,
okay,
no more than
crazy.
There's this,
there should be a farm or something.
I mean for real I'm like,
what do you do with Mike Tyson
related violence and we have no use for it other than in that one thing that you
can only really do until you're 27
well Mike Tyson actually I believe has a one man show in Vegas now is what I've
been hearing.
I've been hearing.
It's really good and what it is is he just sits down and tells stories of his
life just like that.
But they put a structure to it and they know,
they know like he knows like how to do it and apparently is a great stage
presence and apparently it's really compelling because that's great.
It's great.
Yeah.
Was sitting there with boxing history when,
how old are you?
38 I was,
I'm 44 when I was in 1986 I was 19 years old and I remember when Mike Tyson
fights would come on when I was,
I remember when Mike Tyson fights would come on.
Everybody would fucking gathering room.
They would all gather round.
It was,
it was something different.
It wasn't like,
Hey,
there's a boxing match this weekend.
Even Marvin Hagler come on.
Marvin Hagler fan were assaults.
Primal.
Yeah.
There was something like where they're going to let a dog attack.
Like there's something,
an animal is going to like something horrifying.
It's going to happen.
He's a part of the sports history.
There was no one,
no one I think today can appreciate how dominant he was when he was in his
prime.
Yeah,
especially amongst the general public.
There's a few people that question whether or not,
you know he's ever fight a guy like Carl the truth.
Williams had a really good jab,
apparently had great training sessions with him,
and it was like call the truth is the guy to beat Tyson.
Right?
But then by the time Tyson got to Carl the truth,
he fucked him up.
He was cut.
Tyson was on a completely different level by that point.
Well that they were all
out in 40 seconds.
Well,
Larry Holmes and people will get mad and it's like,
well,
he's that fucking good.
Larry Holmes was older when he fought them,
you know,
so I won.
I would have loved to have seen a prime Larry Holmes.
Larry Holmes gave him a hard time with the jab in the first round,
but in the sac around Tyson just started moving his head more,
found its rhythm,
eventually caught him with a monster,
punched,
dropped him,
and then knocked him out in a really fucked up way where his leg went backwards
behind them.
And then ain't,
I remember that it was really,
well,
you looked at it was like his leg.
It's fucked.
And uh,
you know,
Larry Holmes was a long time heavyweight champion.
Nobody had ever done that to Larry.
Guys are beating Larry,
but nobody ever had done that to him.
Yeah.
So that kind of was like,
he's such a historic,
he made dudes look retarded.
There was scary.
He would literally make them look like they would pass out in a way.
It's like,
Yo do crazy shit.
People don't need to see that.
Like,
oh look like a drunk they making you make women men look like drunk ants.
Yeah.
But when he won the title,
he did that.
Remember who the fuck did he fight?
That guy who was a bourbon bourbon want to be being a reverend and shit and
doing a bunch of other nutty shit.
I think he got murdered too.
Why do I know he did a lot?
I feel like there's a lot of shit got murdered.
Uh,
I don't think,
I can't rule that out.
Yeah,
that's very possible.
But the idea of Mike Tyson telling you all those stories,
what it was like to be that guy,
you know,
back then when he was on top of the fucking world.
I mean he was a fucking monster.
The other thing about Mike Tyson is he's a,
he's the Mike Tyson of self loathing as well.
Meaning he'll just be like,
I'm a piece of shit.
And it's like,
whoa man.
But it's,
there's something.
So arresting about somebody saying that.
Yeah.
Trevor Barbara was murdered man.
Yeah,
he won the title from Trevor Berbick.
You remember that?
Um,
one thing that Tyson did for the movie where he's talking about his mindset as
he was walking to the cage,
uh,
and they were telling they raped him.
No,
no,
no.
He was walking and he was like,
he goes,
I'm walking to the cage.
I'm nervous.
I'm nervous and thinking about this,
I'm looking at the crowd,
I'm looking at him,
I'm trying to make eye contact and then they get clothes.
I get more and more confident.
I get calmed down,
I'm a god.
And he just an it would be when it's just like the way he said it,
like he just be like,
oh yeah,
what the fuck would it feel like if you had got it and if you're traveling in a
rot.
When he fought Leon Leon when he fought Michael Spinks,
that was a one of the,
one of the big fights Tyson's career and Michael Spinks was a former light
heavyweight champion who had gone up to heavyweight and Pete and Larry Holmes by
decision,
but there was a look in his eyes when they were reading it.
You know when the,
when the guy was going over the rules and they were looking at each other.
Mike Tyson was just chomping back and forth and just staring at the way he wears
his towel.
They need kind cut a hole in a towel and you hear that quote attributed to that
walk in and you think about that fight and what it must've been like to be
Michael Spinks in the room with at that moment the most impressive heavyweight
fighter in the history of the sport in my opinion.
You've got to judge a guy on what he does to the tough fights when he's in his
prime at his best.
And Mike Tyson in his prime at its best,
which is run through dude.
That's what I wonder.
What do you think happens if he fights Ali at his prime?
It's not a match,
right?
No,
I think he might.
I think he might get Ollie.
I think he just gets him in the first round.
I think it would get them,
you know,
Henry Cooper knocked down Ali and had him badly hurt and custom auto had
or no,
rather um,
oh,
what the fuck's his name?
The guy that just died,
uh,
are uh,
Bundini entity.
Jesus Christ.
Oh,
Bert Sugar.
No,
no,
no.
W who is,
um,
sugar ray Leonard is a trainer.
Angelo Dundee.
Angelo didn't Dundee cut his gloves so that they would have time to recover.
They,
he got back to the corner and they cheated.
They cut his fucking gloves cause he got knocked down by Henry Cooper.
You know,
Ali later as he got older,
got way better.
But if they bolted fought like when they were both the same age when Tyson was
21 and Ali was 21 Tyson when it killed him,
he was,
yeah.
Or even like the Thrilla in Manila or like the or the the,
the foreman won one.
You know,
a lot of people don't want to think of,
you know,
Ali in the later years because he got,
battered and broken up and they're absolutely right.
But even at his best,
he still got caught.
He got caught by something and he never got,
he never fought anybody like Tyson.
He never fought anybody like the Tyson that fought Marvis Frazier.
Jesus fucking Christ.
No vacuuming,
Gary.
That was,
it was,
it was like,
it was like the Christians and the lions.
It was fucking crazy.
No one's,
no one's confusing Muhammad Ali with Myers Frazier.
But I'm saying some of those might have got through and if some of those got
through,
that would have been the end in my mind.
Foreman would give them a fight.
Fuck yea.
Wood for wood from Africa.
Fuck yeah.
From when we were kings fired back a heavy bag and she was just like,
well you know,
that's the thing.
A good thing you could say about Ali as well,
cause I only had an incredible Chen.
I'll leak,
could fuck it,
take it,
he could take it.
But nobody ever hit him with the kind of combinations to Tyson was capable of
throwing Tyson through ungodly things that had never existed in the heavyweight
division before.
Nobody had ever ripped the body to the head like the way he did.
Well,
he would throw that right,
right hook to the body and then that writing opera cut and his whole body would
involve
the dolphin thing where it's just like,
you know,
there's a lot of boxing people would totally disagree with me and they say,
oh,
it's so disrespectful to Muhammad Ali and he was the greatest.
He was amazing.
But I think things evolve and athletes evolve and you,
you got to excel if you want to try to put them era to era and say,
well if,
what if Mohammed Ali grew up during Tyson's Aaron's,
right?
He would be,
he would have been better.
Muhammad Ali would have been better if you grew up in that generation it would,
and that's not,
that's not bullshit.
And Muhammad Ali was an amazing athlete,
but he was an amazing athlete in the 1960s if he was an amazing athlete in the
year 2000 he'd be even fucking better.
For sure I you're set.
But if you look at them as far as like it's just a window of time and compare.
If you could somehow or another get them in a room and the same physical state
that they have those,
cause those guys are the wait guys are ripped now is completely different.
Tyson was on another level.
Dude,
he was on another level and he didn't sustain it and he did.
He definitely imploded.
He went through,
but when he was on man,
dudes would be terrified of him.
Bruce Seldon went down to a miss.
He hit him and then Bruce Selden winged left hook on him and he fucking stumbled
as the ropes.
He fell.
That might've been like some Kung Fu fear shit where he just knew the end was
coming.
You know,
you do any,
cause I read this book called 10 minute toughness,
which this reminded me of and it's a book about positive visualization just in
whether it's,
it's for athletes and cause I asked an athlete friend of mine like,
do you do any,
any sports psychology thing?
Cause I realized from stand up I was like,
I have no uh,
not defense make but I have no,
I just go like the it basically what happened was I would be in a bad mood and I
mean like I'm going to bomb and then I'd go and bomb.
We're enough.
I would just,
I could feel it,
I could feel that I was going to vote.
It was like you have to be able to overcome that.
The feeling of like,
I don't,
I'm in a bad mood and then like,
so I basically,
it's a simple 10 minute toughness and it's basically just about positive
visualization of said task,
whether it's batting basketball,
you know,
someone said half friend's really into it.
Yeah.
But I found it's really helpful.
Um,
and,
and you also hear fighters and you hear,
you hear,
I know athletes to do it and they,
and Palae used to lay down for half an hour before every game and just visualize
it.
A Michael Jordan Tiger Woods,
same thing
for sure.
That would help.
Yeah,
absolutely.
100%.
Anytime you can equate that thing in your mind with you having success in it,
it's going to implement it.
You do it in your head and then so when you go and do it,
you're basically just executing.
I do Jujitsu in the isolation tank.
I'd do it all the time.
I do it in my head.
I go,
I go over techniques like our force myself to go over a whole series of
techniques.
So like I'll,
I'll,
um,
I'll just get into a state in the isolation tank and then I said,
okay,
let's break down some guard positions and then I just go over guard positions in
my head and where am I?
Where's this arm disarm is wrapping around the knee and pulling it down.
Whereas this,
this hand,
this hand is,
we really try to sensation and then I go through the whole move.
I go through the whole thing in my head cause I know what it feels like to do
it.
I've done it all.
So then I just go through all the moves in my head and I can practice and they
say that you practicing in that manner is actually sometimes better for you than
the actual physical act of practicing and as far as like rate of improvement.
Sure.
Yeah.
No,
I know.
That's what's great about it is that I,
and I don't even fuck around when I say this,
I've gotten 25% better in three months.
Well when you go back to the tank,
do that.
Okay,
good visual is visualize your shows like in a tank,
but you should never be thinking you're going to bomb.
You always is that you're the luckiest fucking person ever because you're going
to go get paid to talk.
Yeah.
That's a,
you're a professional comedian,
which is craziness.
The fact that somehow or another you,
you hit the lottery with choosing something,
going after it and then actually achieving success with it in the point of you
actually get paid to do something that's fun.
Where's the majority of the world gets paid to do something they don't want to
do.
That's why they get money.
They get money because nobody wants to do it.
Or because if they do want to do what they need to be compensated,
because it's not the ideal shit be doing.
Right,
right.
You know,
maybe it's good work,
maybe you enjoy it.
But if you had your choice,
he might be fishing.
Well,
the guy who gets paid to go fishing,
that guy won,
you know,
white trash.
So you're driving to go fishing.
Okay,
you're getting paid.
You got to stink on,
you just have an emotional stink on you and you're like,
they're going to fucking smell it.
And that's where I talked about that genius,
the group,
the collective unconscious thing where it's like they can just smell it.
That's also,
I think where you need love.
Neil Brennan A.
Yeah.
Dot.
And you and I have always been cool with each other.
I know you have had like disagreements with people and I've had disagreements
with people,
but I think when we met each other way,
way back in the day at Boston comedy,
we were always cool with each other because I realized I'm like,
Oh,
here's one of those dudes that people probably fucked with a lot and he seems
really smart.
He's worried that you might fuck with them,
but he seems cool.
So I'll just assure him that I'll never fuck with them.
Right.
That will get along nice.
Yeah,
that's true.
I always felt like,
uh,
a amount of respect from you that wasn't commensurate with my position in life
at that time.
Well that's your two guys that stick out.
You and Jon Stewart that were very nice.
They were very nice before.
That was a thing to be,
that's how you,
no,
how pissed he was that CNN bullshit when he went on and in Carmen's guys hacks
and you know,
and it was angry and wasn't funny at all.
When you realize how nice that guy is,
like to get that guy to go and do something like that.
I've done his show a couple of times or they do the daily show.
He's like the nicest guy ever.
So friendly if he's really that pissed off at you or something.
But I've never thought that anybody is in any,
I mean there's no positions in life.
I think that's nonsense.
I don't,
I don't buy it for a second,
especially as a comedian.
Like why would I ever consider that anybody else would be the,
there.
There are no positions.
You know,
you've got to look at a guy who's got a shit job,
you know,
he's cleaned the bathroom toilets at a a gas station.
Like,
oh well I don't know what happened to him that he got stuck in this situation.
Right?
I'm going to treat this guy entirely based on how he treats me.
You know,
if he comes out and he's got a fucking bucket in his hand and you know,
a a broom and he's just cleaning toilets.
And I asked him,
hey man,
do you know where the highway is?
And he goes,
yeah,
go double back there and take that off.
I'm going to say thank you,
my brother.
Have a good day.
I agree.
I mean,
the thing is I try,
it's like,
what does this guy seem like?
Seems like a good dude.
We're going to be good dudes to each other and that's good.
And I don't like,
then the thing that I like about you being living where you live,
which is far away from La is going,
I don't even like being around that sort of nexus of like,
you will be treated a certain way and you will not be because you're not you,
not in movies.
So you don't,
you get a shitty a parking space and you get a shittier social,
you're going to feel shitty this whole time there is that
man.
I remember I was,
uh,
over a buddy of mine's Xy,
actually,
Brian Callan.
So way back in the day when Brian was a single man and he had this girl that he
was,
uh,
that he had over his place.
And uh,
I,
you know,
she was like just real country.
I forgot what it was,
but Brian was supposed to come with me,
but he was always like making like triple plans,
you know Brian's.
So I'm like,
come on man.
What are you going?
What are we going to do?
Are we going to go out?
Are you going to go out with her and just let me know now?
And she's like,
God,
she goes,
the way acts,
you would think he wasn't like the fifth lead on a Sitcom.
She goes,
you only like the fifth lead.
Relax.
And I'll never forget that.
They never that.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
I was like,
what are you trying to even know what number I was?
I don't know what number
call sheet.
I fucking said I was the fifth lead out of,
cause I was,
there was eight people on the sick and maybe,
I guess my name came in five or six or whatever the fuck it was.
She knew it.
My,
come on.
You know that.
How crazy.
I had a girl laugh at me.
She goes,
you write for Nickelodeon.
Like it's a good gig.
I was fucking excited to write for Nicola.
You know what I mean?
Like I'm fucking,
any job in Showbiz is fucking a good job as far as I'm concerned.
Show.
Did you write for all that meaning and Kell being in that hive of Showbiz?
There's too many crazy people in the wrong kind of crazy.
I can't get anything out of that and no one acts natural.
I don't ever talk about it.
It's like I always say standing next to a celebrity is like driving next to a
cop.
Right.
He can't fucking at,
you can do a facsimile of what you think naturalist,
but everyone's acting fishy.
Fucking everyone.
So I just try to stay away from it.
Smart.
Yeah,
it's definitely smart.
You know?
Uh,
you're,
you're way better off outside the hive.
The hive of a,
of this show Biz culture is just so,
so oversaturated with insecurity and insanity.
It's just too much nonsense and too much crazy people.
Too much,
too much need.
Like I don't want it.
I don't want to talk about the business.
I don't want,
I don't want to talk about any of this.
This is all boring shit.
Like this is a crazy world out there and we're,
we're concentrating on some of the most mundane aspects of it.
Yeah.
Just because it's the latest obsession and you also have to realize when you
have a place like this that is essentially the vortex of all things,
where someone,
all,
all instances where people get a preposterous amount of attention for no reason.
It all comes from here.
So all these people who watch all these different shows,
the housewives shows this show,
they gravitate towards here somehow or another.
This is going to be the place where they get on TV.
And there's people right now that are out of their fucking mind.
They'd been a God damn nightmare to everyone they've ever met their entire life.
And they're on a bus right now and they're headed over here because they're
going to get fucking famous.
They're going to get the jet get out of jail free card.
They're going to get on a reality show.
Yeah.
And guess what?
I,
they'll going to get it.
They're going to get on a rally show.
They will.
They'll get on one.
I
have hosted one.
I know how it works.
I know how they cast.
They find someone.
If that guy can fucking form a sentence and he's energetic and he looks at,
it might be a narcissist.
Huge narcissist.
Perfect.
He's like flexing in front of the mirror.
He shaves his socks,
you know,
whatever.
We're socks go hook.
I think any crazy person right now could,
could come here and come here just to try to get famous and that's not a good
place to live.
You got a good place to live with.
That's the big percentage of people come here to get famous.
That's unhealthy.
Yeah.
I just try to ignore it and try to,
but you're in the hive,
right?
Are you in the hall?
I live in Venice.
Yeah.
That's the hive sun,
but not really.
Not hippy high.
Yeah.
Not compare it to a knock compared to Hollywood.
If you haven't a lot of knowing of people.
A lot of annoying people live in Venice.
Yeah,
I agree.
It's a different kind of anointment.
Yeah,
it's a hippy annoying,
which I find forgivable.
Yes,
and almost part also ignore.
I'm in my head.
It's like I drive there and then Topanga Canyon is a lot like that too.
Right?
There's a lot of hippie.
Topanga is very hippie.
Yeah.
God bless him.
I'm not really done with that.
They annoy me for the most part.
Yeah.
Hippies.
We've talked about this,
but you have said with like most hippies,
oh yeah,
I'm friends with a lot of hippies,
but there's a lot of hippies that I don't like.
I became a an anti hippie person when I lived in boulder and then I got to
experience hippies on a daily basis.
There was,
well,
you being Vegan,
this is like
weakness.
There's a lot of weakness and illogical thinking and I've had some conversations
with hippies,
you know,
the were know quasi debates about shit and they'd go south real quick.
There's not a lot of logic behind the real slave one move.
The real sloppy,
Lazy Hippie.
You know,
like you ever hear the people that Peter Schiff always debates at occupy Wall
Street and he goes down there and talks to the sloppy hippies cause they don't
really have coherent sentences and it's really,
he's battering them around.
It's Mike Tyson sparks one of us.
It's not fair.
And the,
those motherfuckers are the,
there's too many of those.
There's too many sloppy hippies who don't really have a good handle on how
complex different social issues are.
And they will,
why should you add all the money?
Do well,
that's why you need $500 million,
man.
What do you need that man?
And he just eviscerates him.
Peter Shift just explains lead on a Sitcom that was a fucking upgrade.
Stepped.
Well,
you know what?
I haven't,
but I do get in the tank and think about it.
Yeah,
that's the,
yeah,
there are two.
There's a lot of fluffy hippies and uh,
and sloppy thinking,
man.
Yeah.
Well that's what I like about your point of view is that it's humane and
masculine.
I don't find it as like people go like fucking Europe frat boy.
No,
it's not that easy.
Not a frat boy.
He's fucking jock.
No,
not that simple.
I don't even know the rules to football.
How about that?
You have to know what's going on.
People get in trouble and the whistle would blow and shit.
And I'm like,
Whoa,
what happened?
Who,
what?
Yeah.
I Dunno.
I don't know what a point is.
Why do some,
why are some things more points sometimes like you know,
they run across the line of certain point,
but if it goes through the net,
it's a different point.
Right?
It goes through the goals.
Guess what?
I don't give a fuck you like,
but you'd like fighting.
Yeah.
That's the only thing.
Well that and professional pool.
Which most boring as fuck.
Yeah,
like professional basketball.
Dia.
Yeah.
Do you play basketball?
I used him.
Um,
and I just like,
it's a fun.
Yeah,
it's a very fast paced,
fast paced.
A lot of dudes,
there's a,
there's a rhythm to it.
There's some,
there's a lot of dudes Naylin shit.
I love a dude who fades back for a fucking three point jump shots.
It just is all net.
I love excellence in any form,
but it doesn't mean anything to me when that ball goes in the net.
I know it's really hard to do though.
So when I watch it,
it's pretty bad ass,
but it doesn't sustain me very well.
What's funny is when you see like you watch TV and then you're around the people
and you just go,
oh,
when you go you're,
you're sitting near the court or whatever and you just like,
oh,
I understand why they're paid $20 million because this is fucking weird.
They're weird to begin with.
And then there they figured out this weird skill I would assume.
I'm amazed like that.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
Where do you see a guy fight and you're like,
man,
and then you see me,
you're like,
all right,
what do you mean?
Like if you see a guy fight on tape and then you kind of think one thing and
then you see him fight live and you're like,
ah,
okay,
I might be the only person that has seen more people fight live then seeing
people fight.
I that's,
I thought that as I was saying,
I see you did not do a lot of prep.
Well I do.
I'm Wa my prep really is what I would be doing anyway.
I'm such a fanatic about MMA that I don't have to do any extra shit.
Like,
and I asked him for shit,
like the UFC will give me shit all the time.
We'll say,
hey,
I need a,
I need some video on like Kennan Borow or something like that.
I want to watch the videos so they'll uh,
they'll send me some shit.
So I'm like constantly being like fed stuff,
just out of my own curiosity.
Like I want to see,
I missed one of his fights in WWII.
See,
can he send me Miguel Torres when he fought Brian Bolt?
And,
and by doing that,
that's natural for me.
I just want to,
I want to see those.
I'm always like breaking down like fights in my head as far as like,
like fights that went on in the past.
Are you think shit,
are you good at all?
I ever really predict,
but not predicting,
but I have to be a,
you have to be pretty over the top for me to not predict,
but I'm saying like,
do you,
are you,
are you surprised by most outcomes?
I'm surprised often.
Yeah.
I don't think I could,
uh,
I don't think,
I don't think I could ever guess better than 50,
50.
I don't think it's,
I'm in maybe shit,
maybe.
I'm never really thought about it.
I've never really seen,
I try to be as objective as possible.
The Tyson Foreman Ali,
I don't make that ultimate decision.
I tried to,
I tried to be as objective as possible and it's cause I'm not betting,
I don't have to make that ultimate decision.
So what I do is I sit down and I go,
man,
if he tour gets them,
Vito has got some fast fucking hands of veto,
comes out guns blazing,
might catch them
and then I go,
but what a Vandelay can get this motherfucker and did the second round and what
have you started landing?
Some leg kicks.
What if he can keep his hands up high and avoid the flurry and somehow or
another where Vitara what if he turns it into a dog fight,
you know,
and then you start going back and forth.
But I don't know what's going to happen.
You know,
I never say this is going to happen.
I only say this guy should probably be aware of this and that guy should
probably be aware of that and let's fucking see because it's such a crazy
fucking sport.
The human jaw was never designed to be punched.
It was just designed to chew food.
That's it.
And when you start punching that motherfucker and when you punch heads,
heads were designed to take a certain amount of impact for the lumps and bumps
that you're going to get going through life.
But it's not designed to take one,
two,
three combinations with a fucking Shin kick at the end of them.
Nobody takes that.
Your,
your,
your brains like what the fuck is happening,
right?
We hitting an asteroid field like what's going on here?
Your body,
your body's just not designed for finding,
it's so weak.
And especially in comparison to other animals,
man,
are a lot of those guys getting concussed and longterm brain damage fit?
Well,
the steroid,
there are guys for sure that are going to have some issues with what they called
pugilistic dementia depending upon when they retire.
Oh,
you followed all the football guys.
Yes,
it's coming.
It's fuck,
I don't,
I think that it's gonna I think it's going to sport will be different in five
years.
How would they change it though?
I think that they will go,
someone pointed out,
just put the fucking a diff,
you know the,
the,
the helmets that uh,
soccer players wear now?
No,
they're not.
How much,
they're almost like a,
not fleeces soccer players wear helmets.
Soccer Goalie.
I saw yesterday wearing one and little kids wearing too because the kids are
getting concussions from playing soccer.
Yes,
they're getting traumatic brain injury.
But that's what I'm saying.
Careers that's happening.
But kid yet so,
so I saw a goalie in a,
in a,
in a Manchester and wearing one of those things and I think that that's what
football will come to.
Wow.
How's that going to stop the traumatic brain injuries?
Ah,
cause if you're not wearing a helmet,
you're not going to go head first into a guy.
So they won't be wearing helmets.
I,
there'll be wearing,
in my head they were wearing like soft,
like whatever.
This,
I don't know what the fuck they're called.
They're like,
they're like soft helmets.
Meaning when guys were leather,
so like the leather head guys,
they weren't,
it wasn't as violent because they're protecting their head.
I completely agree with you.
I completely agree with you in theory,
but people are so stupid.
I don't think you can sell that.
What I'm worried about is the legal ramifications for sports.
One of the reasons why they probably couldn't sell it.
You could never sell,
hey,
the way to protect people's,
give them less protection.
I think you'll like pick one.
Every win,
win football players are now just suing the NFL on mass.
I think that they're going to,
it's going to be a legal problem and I think the NCAA is going to have the same
problem.
I think lied every level,
every level of football is going to have it.
They fucked up down there too.
Yeah.
Yeah,
they do.
Right guys get not diagnosed.
Guys can put back in games.
They can't remember.
I didn't even think about college ball.
I didn't even say in high school.
I mean all the time they get to the pros.
They probably already experienced it.
Gang and the or the in high school as well,
like and and so that's the thing.
It's like they're not going to be able to ensure this shit if there's enough.
It's funny lawsuits for cause.
Just for a few minutes of that conversation,
I didn't even consider the fact that they had gone through college career as
well.
I just for whatever reason thought of them as professional athletes,
you know?
Yeah,
I do.
It wasn't even thinking no.
These guys there,
this is an organized sport.
This isn't like MMA.
They actually have to go through a high school career and then a college career.
Think about all the m that's also violent.
Whew.
What a and you know,
just hope you can get enough out of your body that you can make enough money.
You can squirrel away and live semite comparably in pain for the rest of your
life when it's over.
Yes.
And that's the thing,
it's a former athlete.
It's like you want to talk about needing a farm.
Yeah.
I always do a joke.
A buddy of mine who like if you lose,
like whenever I see a former athlete,
I always feel like they should be with a girl.
They should be saying to the girl like,
you should've been here eight years ago.
Shit was really popping off them,
but now they're just limping and fucking,
they're not famous.
They're hunched over.
They got their bodies are fucking shot.
Yeah,
you can get hurt playing football,
man.
That's a,
that's a way more brutal sport on your body in my opinion,
than MMA.
MMA is pretty rough.
Don't get me wrong.
I mean it's not a working in it at all,
but MMA fucking 48 minutes or however long.
Well,
more importantly,
it's not dudes running at you full speed and then watching their rock and they
have splotching them Chopin special shoes.
Dig into the dirt bedroom.
Come on man.
And they're on every God damn Mexican supplement known to man.
I mean these mother fuckers,
when they say that they test the NFL,
yeah,
they test.
If you talk shit and you get in an argument with somebody,
they'll fucking pull your purse out and pull your card.
You think those guys aren't on the juice,
you gotta be out of your mind.
There's no way humans are that big.
If they are,
we need to find out what the fuck they're putting in burgers.
Why is,
why have humans grown so much over the past few years and not lost any pesky
decades
just as fast?
Well,
there's for sure there's better methods as far as training and they're the more
sat Tiffany,
but they're not that much.
But I mean,
that's the thing is it's not fucking,
you can't be fucking six 10.
Did you ever see Bob Sapp?
No.
You never seen Bob Sapp who is me?
Bob Sapp was the ultimate MMA experiment as far as like,
he was a football player.
I'm pro football player who became the ultimate MMA experiment in that,
how much can you do?
How much shit can you do?
How big can you get?
And would that overcome technique and skill?
And the answer,
and a lot of cases was the beginning.
It was,
yes.
He just knocked his job.
Actually,
he knocked,
he beat Ernesto hoost twice.
And so who's,
this is world famous kickboxer.
Bob Sapp is 370 pounds with a six pack of abs and a body that doesn't even look
real.
It doesn't look real.
And he throws punches and kicks.
God Ra coordinated.
Yeah.
I mean fairly coordinated.
He music clearly like many,
many skill levels below Ernesto hoost.
But Ernesto,
who's just couldn't deal with the physical power of his own slot.
It was just too big.
It was 370 pound man just coming out with those didn't exist before.
Get a guy that big.
Yeah.
You,
if you see him,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna pull it up because you just can't believe it.
It just,
you won't believe that that's a real human being.
You won't believe it.
Uh,
yeah.
So I'm of the mind that it's gonna it's gonna Change.
You know those Cryo chambers now?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I don't do to that.
Like the couple Mba guys.
The Sun is actually just bought one.
Yeah.
A hyperbaric chamber.
No,
it's,
I don't think that's what,
it's a cryogenic chamber.
It was guys will freeze there.
Coby does it.
Dirk does it.
The Sun's just bought one.
Um,
my buddy Blake Griffin does it and he sent me a video.
You get into,
you get naked in a,
basically it looks like just the Chamber Austin Powers.
Cause you can't believe this shit.
And he frees herself.
You can't believe it.
That's what he looks like when he fights guys.
That's real.
Look at that picture.
That's like six foot,
four,
370 pounds.
And he's fighting some poor kickboxer.
Some poor dude is slaying gloves with that guy.
And that's what he does.
He gets on top of them,
holds them down and smashes him.
It's fucking insane.
Yeah.
He did that to Ernesto hoost.
I mean you,
you look at that image and you go,
how is a human being dead pig?
They've never existed that big
before.
Yeah,
no.
So,
so,
uh,
the,
you get no chamber,
it's negative 300 degrees.
Whoa.
For how long?
For like 32nd spurts.
For like two minutes.
30 seconds.
I don't know if it's 30 seconds,
I could be dead wrong.
It's some,
and what happens is all of your blood,
your body thinks you're just freezing to death.
So all of your blood goes to your core and gets replenished in what would
normally take 24 hours.
Whoa.
So basically you can work out twice.
You can do two,
four hour workouts full four hour,
like rejuvenate your body.
I've never heard of this before.
Cry.
I mean I'll shake it,
but experiencing a cryogenic chamber cry or cry to cryotherapy.
Koby Bryant,
there's one in,
uh,
um,
what,
uh,
in like Hancock Park,
the guy has one and the,
and the NBA teams are starting to use them.
Well,
you know,
anything that can increase your recovery is where it's at.
You know?
Wow.
Freezes body and negative 166 degree Cairo
therapy.
That's I say Cryo Cryo therapy.
Wow.
Yeah.
First article about it.
That's a fuck man.
That's good.
And you just,
it's like,
it's fucking bananas,
man.
Wow.
This is nuts man.
Let's see how long it says they got recovery boots,
which is something that they were,
if they have it basically is like the,
the um,
the,
the thing that when you get your heart rate checked,
when they blow it up and inflates and tightens your muscles,
guys will wear it.
The guys in the NBA where those at night for a couple hours and it just goes
through their law and just fucking there.
They're just machines.
That's the thing is they just drink themselves like machines.
Yeah,
they have to be all.
Okay.
All the Lakers are going on this thing.
They went to Sara Sacramento.
Go on this thing.
Yeah.
Wow.
Jesus.
Hold on.
I have video of it.
Do you really?
Not a lot.
What if that shit breaks and that's how you some guide,
I heard some guy froze his socks to his feet but that sounds like that sounds
maybe when I'm done.
How long it goes for [inaudible] and sweaty feet and you went in there.
Oh you crazy bitch.
Because you imagine
raising money flows comm 200 degrees below zero where they were kept there for
three minutes before being released.
What three minutes?
How's that possible?
Because they don't do it straight through.
I don't understand that.
Uh,
they do it in spurts so that you don't fucking freeze.
Lakers were split into groups of four and placed into a room that was
approximately 60 degrees below Fahrenheit for one minute.
Okay?
So they went to a 60 degree below zero room for one to chill,
just to chill.
Once their body's got used to the cold climate,
the players walked into an adjacent room with a temperature was approximately
200 degrees below zero when they were kept there for three minutes before being
released.
All right.
Like I would not want to do that.
How was that possible?
All right,
here's Blake.
Oh my God,
I hit few.
Hit play.
So if you tried to pee right after that,
you're shooting like slushy.
Who is this gentleman?
Blake Griffin
from the Los Angeles Clippers.
Oh my God.
He's freezing his dick off.
Literally.
Look at that.
Do you go up to,
can you insulate your Dick?
How's that work?
I don't think you can grease it up.
See how maybe you could graze it off.
I'm just worried about crack
but like motor oil outright about it cracking.
Like if somebody hits you in it just shattered and they couldn't repair your
Dick.
Yeah.
No,
but you see when it hits he goes like,
Woo.
Yeah,
that looks horrendous.
It looks like Austin Powers.
It looks horrendous.
It looks for it.
And I guess they don't do it to the brain though,
Huh?
Uh,
yeah.
I guess keep your head the fuck out.
Yeah.
It keeps the body a under that thing,
but they don't do it to the brain and I think that might be the key to your
survival.
That's how you're getting through that.
This is correct because you could probably go
for that long without much oxygen.
You're not going to be doing too much breathing while you're a at 200 degrees
below zero.
That's the thing about a cold water that fucks people up to your,
your,
your desire for oxygen increases dramatically.
And your ability to hold air in your lungs reduces magic dramatically.
And these are the recovery boots and he's six 10.
Wow.
And they look like fucking,
I don't even know how to describe those.
I've seen those before.
Ryan Parsons turned me on to that shit.
It's like compressing it compresses sections of your leg.
Yeah,
I've seen that before.
Is it looks like a,
like a fucking ski bag.
Yeah.
These guys were athletes on it.
Just completely different level these days.
Um,
and what happens if they come up with genetic engineering?
Man,
that's,
that's when things are really gonna get bizarre when they have the ability to
engineer the body to make it faster and make it,
you know,
the,
with Myostatin inhibitors make it so that your body produces more muscle and
stay keeps on you.
Well that's what I actually,
yeah,
actually the thought where when,
when I was talking to Ken Sake,
Jose Conseco was on the podcast.
The champs.
Yeah.
How's that?
You'd study.
It was interesting.
It was really interesting.
It's just went up.
It's real.
But I was thinking,
I just thought after amps.
Yeah.
I the thought afterward that he,
they should've done a thing in the MLB where you could have one,
you could have a designated juicer where there was one guy on your team that you
could bring in who was on fucking Roy [inaudible] and then they could have one
picture that was on roids cause he was saying that he used to knock pet it up,
Andy Pettitte,
Apidra.
And they were both juiced up.
Oh.
So it's like,
it'd be like,
and here comes the fucking,
the Yankees juicer.
Like if they,
if there was a guy on every team,
you could have one
juicer.
When I was 19,
I met 10 say go when I was working at the Boston athletic club,
but didn't meet him as much as I gazed upon his presence person.
And it was,
he was at the peak of his popularity and,
uh,
he walked into the weight room with the boss.
I felt like I couldn't fucking believe how big he was.
He was fucking enormous man.
He's just cartoonish car fucking tune.
It's,
you don't realize that when you those baseball outfits.
Yeah.
Cause those outfits are kind of emasculating.
No,
but if you saw that dude with a tank top on and go,
what the fuck?
You'd be like what am I?
Yeah,
what am I,
yeah,
he's an enormous
uh,
but yeah,
that's the,
these,
yeah just they fucking,
once they get into that,
cause this is genetic.
That's all legal.
You're just freezing your butt.
They're going to,
it's going to get more and more and more and it's going to be,
it's still remain legal,
right?
Yeah.
It is going to get more.
Did you see that thing now where they said if you run differently you can cut
your training time down where if you run in 32nd sprints,
did he say that it was in the New York Times and then a guy just wrote a book
about it?
If you,
if you,
you can run for like,
you can burn the same of calories
and get your metabolism going and get your heart rate going in basically six
minutes.
What would normally take 20 if you sprint for 30 seconds,
John,
for 30 sprint jog,
sprint,
jog,
and you're done.
Really getting your heart,
heart rate up is the thing.
It was at the time was probably six weeks ago.
So you sprint full clip.
Yeah.
So do you do this on a treadmill or do you do this?
You can do it either.
You can eat,
I mean,
I think treadmill would be better.
She would probably do it on an elliptical machine to write.
Just go crazy 30 seconds and,
and stuff.
Uh,
and then jog.
Yeah,
that I,
that is great because it's fucking save time.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
You know,
like you were saying about kettle bells,
you can bang out a workout and get it done in 20 minutes.
You're done.
I've got a video man and it's a extreme kettlebell cardio DVD.
I got it from a dragon door.com and when you do this,
this thing,
it's maybe I can get 45 minutes into this and I'm fucking dead.
I'm done man.
And you're in great shape for day.
Like there's kettlebells push ups,
first babies,
they go,
how long did you work out?
Like 45 minutes Max.
That's all I can do.
They're like,
that's all you could do.
It does the gym for fucking two hours.
Thug and did my lats did the,
yeah and then,
but you also don't even know what you ever do.
The thing with kettlebells where you're like,
why is that sore?
I didn't even fucking know anything.
And you're like,
you're lower thigh will be sore and you're just like,
man,
I guess I did something.
It makes it use Turkish getups you ever do those?
Is that that one it looks really stupid.
You know you lie on your back and you do like a press.
I think that's the one.
Where are you going to stand up stupid as Fox.
The best thing ever.
It looks really hard,
but you just lay on your back with a weight and then you just slowly stand up
and tell you something to do that with 70 pounds,
hold that,
hold 70 pounds up and slowly stand up and do it in a controlled manner and do it
for like sets of 10 woo,
Woo doggy body.
Be on fire,
your lower back and your abs and everything.
Your arm,
your shoulder,
everything's on fire.
Kettle bells or did,
did Ferris get you on him?
No,
I've been doing them for years.
I've been doing them for a long time.
Like I didn't know him.
Like my friend Jamie was a personal trainer and he uh,
was a real big on these fucking things.
I'd never even heard of them before we started just doing swings.
Just kettlebell swings.
Yeah.
Amazing.
That's what's great for your back,
for your ass.
That's what Gabe took my ass from a 3.5 to a seven.
How many do you do?
What do you do it?
How do you do it?
Fucking three sets of 60 yeah.
Oh,
you do lightweight and just do a lot of them.
Do you ever do bodyweight?
No,
but I also,
it's the I am,
I am only 150 pounds.
So if I do 30 pounds,
right,
that's a lot.
Yeah.
It's not lightweight.
It's like something you do in reps,
the 60.
Now that's a lot.
But by imagining announcer,
bodyweight squats,
they're amazing man.
They're called Hindu squats.
If you look at it online,
just Google a Hindu squats on youtube,
but you,
uh,
it's just full body weight.
You dropped
down and you're actually heals.
Come off the ground.
You're on the tip of your toes and your ass and you're,
you're,
um,
ankles collide and then you stand all the way up.
So you drop all the way down and all the way up and you,
if you watch it online,
you can see like there's a lot of,
um,
videos that'll show you the correct way to do it.
It's real simple.
But once you understand the movement that it's all about just doing massive
numbers of them trying to get as you can.
I do a set of 210.
It took a long time to get there though.
I started,
it would be a hundred and I would have to stop.
I could do 200 before,
but I had to take like a break.
But now I can do 200 straight,
200 hundreds hard.
But I'm not,
I'm doing two 10 now.
That's my next thing.
I want to do two 10 I want to build up to 500 that's what I want to eventually
do.
Yeah.
But I think that's possible.
I think it's a good,
it's a good um,
demonstration of willpower to,
uh,
it's a good exercise for me cause I like to disassociate when I'm doing
repetitive exercise.
Things that can cause you to second guess yourself.
Right.
And intense exercise.
The exercise about quitting intense physical.
I mean,
nobody's in my room,
nobody's screaming.
I don't have a drill sergeant.
It's just me.
So the way I motivate myself is I make myself do shit where I have to silence
that voice of quitting where there's no getting through it unless we do 400 is
just that,
that's what we're doing.
There's nothing,
there's nothing.
Just concentrate on the number and keep going.
There is no quitting.
It doesn't,
it doesn't exist.
And as long as I never quit when I'm doing that,
then that is just my modus operandi.
That's how,
that's how I operate.
And uh,
I,
I do it as like an exercise.
That's how it got smoking about negative shit.
Yeah,
I know.
Now if I smoke one cigarette,
I'm going to smoke 10,000.
So I just got to stop.
How long did you smoke for 10 years.
I was just like,
I'm never smoking.
I just made the decision.
I'm never smoking again.
How much better did you feel when he stomped?
Uh,
it was 10 years ago,
so I don't even remember.
But yeah,
you feel way better.
More energy,
more like,
and more everything.
Um,
and that's,
and you just,
just kinda like,
okay,
I'm not going to smoke again.
Somebody had talked to poor Brian Port Brian,
someone's got to tell him to quit smoking.
He's smoking.
Just decide not to.
Man,
you're right.
He won't listen to you.
He doesn't care.
He's,
he's positive.
He's never getting cancer.
There's no worries.
I use it for my voice.
Keeps some sexy.
Does it keep me a second,
my voice and it actually use it for meals.
Like today,
I'm not even going to have a chance to eat today.
That's a good move.
That's for sure.
But now that I,
you want me to be able to fight off that something I can get behind,
but he's not even going to be healthy enough to fight off the cancer because he
used it as a dietary aide.
I gotta take a leak.
I got to take the king of all leaks.
All right.
Go ahead and we'll talk about you where you're gone and we'll wrap this shit up
as soon as you get back.
Cause we've been doing it for like two and a half hours,
right?
Yeah.
We have a nice house show and oh yeah,
we're in Pasadena in a couple hours.
If you're around,
if you're not crazy or a stalker,
can't wait to see Thomson [inaudible]
again,
you haven't seen him in awhile.
Tom's grows that shit.
He's a great guy.
Um,
Fort Lauderdale this weekend,
a Saturday night is a essentially sold out.
Um,
I think there was a few tickets left for the early show,
but those might be gone.
Um,
and uh,
the Friday show has some tickets left and the Sunday show has some tickets left,
but they're going fast.
It should be a good time to,
I'm with Dunkin and Dunkin has been in the fucking groove.
He,
I took him with me to the Louisville Improv and it was amazing.
First of all,
he was getting standing ovations going on stage,
which is crazy.
He didn't do the little hall by once.
He's,
he crushed it though.
He's got a lot of new material to Dunkin is just,
he's so fun to be with you.
So prolific too.
He's a,
he's going to be a great comedian now.
I mean he's already a great comedian,
but I mean I think he's going to be like a great national headlines.
That next girl,
you think that's going to get them.
I think that's going to give him now he has a poster for sale.
Go to his website and buy it.
It's awesome.
I have one in the studio,
Duncan trussell.com t r u s s e l l a,
and there's still some tickets available for next Friday's late show at the
tabernacle in Atlanta.
I got two shows.
I'm felling my special.
I'm fucking fired up.
Who's ongoing?
April 20th Joey Dheas Duncan Trussell and you're going?
Yeah.
Okay.
Did they get your tickets and everything else?
You're all set and Mike Maxwell actually made a poster and he's going as well.
And a,
you could buy that post for I think on maximum.
What is it?
Mike Maxwell may find them on Twitter.
Yeah,
he'll be there tonight too.
I'm going to sign some pictures,
but yeah,
Mike Maxwell art on Twitter.
You can find the link to his website and on his website you can find the link to
the poster.
It looks dope.
He's a killer artist.
He did my poster for the Chicago show.
I think he still has a few of those available too.
He's amazing and great art and a great guy.
Really Fun guy to hang out with,
so I'm just like that.
He's going to be there in Atlanta.
Good vibes.
And can I say my thing?
Me and Joey Diaz are coming to Columbus,
Ohio.
The first show is sold out,
so they added a second show,
May 17th,
and then May 8th in the woodlands.
Ah,
yeah.
That's a good run.
It's a good one,
right?
Yeah.
May 18th I think we're in Cleveland.
And then May 19th,
Pittsburgh,
uh,
the tickets or at desk squad.
Dot.
TV.
Now you,
um,
what does the woodlands,
what does that,
it's a,
this kid.
It's like just a bar,
but it's got a good room.
It's got her stand up.
Pretty decent room for standup.
Yeah,
like a duck Stan hope room,
that kind of plays.
And they're doing a lot of comedy there.
Yeah,
I think so.
Dylan Shelton books and he does good shops.
Columbus has like a bit of a comedy scene,
right?
But mostly because of the punchline,
because people want to die there and they just wanted to laugh,
so it's loud.
Is it that bad if you were to go,
I know dude,
Columbia,
I was just in Ohio.
I was in Cincinnati.
That shit was pretty grim.
And Gram Chappelle lives in Ohio.
He was so bored that he's like,
dude,
why don't you return your rental car?
I can drive her from Cincinnati
to Cleveland.
I was like,
God,
that's all right man.
Why does he live there?
Cause it's families there and it's a nice place for family raising kids.
Good place.
Right?
But he's just like,
what do you want a good place for you though?
No,
I just don't like what the wetter but,
but if you were to do go there and throw like dating way over your head.
Just really difficult to do there.
Yeah,
you can't do that.
they're all,
nobody's in good shape.
Yeah.
Phaedra.
It's a few of them.
I mean they got boyfriends.
They'll all come to the show on the alarm,
the whatever they get locked up.
You know guys,
since we're talking about dates,
oh Neil Brennan.
Where are you performing?
So tomorrow,
tomorrow,
Thursday,
April 12th through 14th I'm going to be in Bloomington,
Indiana.
Comedy addict would love to see comedy attic and Bloomington,
Indiana is or a website for this joint comedy.
attic.com comedy Anik static,
a t,
t I c o Attic comedy attic comedy addict.com.
Okay.
April.
But it doesn't end there.
April 19th through 21st.
That's next week.
I'm going to be at the stress factory in New Brunswick,
New Jersey.
Wow.
Guys with Vinnie brand 19th through 21st grade club Glee Club.
Uh,
Charlotte May 3rd through fifth,
the comedy zone in Charlotte.
Just don't you have a website motherfucker.
Just keeping out the website because I'm not gonna remember all the branded.com
I'm coming to La Jolla.
Denver.
Charlotte's gonna be off his whole fucking Bloomington.
Well,
you guys fucking,
if he kept going,
we would,
he would have let them.
Fuck you.
Joe Rogan,
who let them cook going.
We'd be here for days.
You're talking about your posters.
Mac Mac's,
walmart.com.
Uh,
anything else?
Seriously.
Neil brennan.com.
[inaudible] Dot com follow me on Twitter doing the comedy store in L'oreal.
Yeah.
Fabulous Room.
One of them.
One of my favorite rooms.
Well,
maybe my favorite room in the world.
It might be,
it might be one of the best run.
I really want to record an album there cause it's 1978 there it does.
Nick depalo recorded his album there.
Did he really?
Yeah,
it's great when it was his first one.
I believe he recorded it there.
It's great.
It's fucking,
the acoustics are perfect.
Yeah.
It's just,
it's,
it's like,
it's easy to,
that's what I mean.
It's easy,
but it doesn't feel cheap.
It feels like we're just in a good mood.
You didn't know Fred,
you never met Fred who uh,
I think Fred's dad who used to run that place,
they fired him some,
some,
I dunno,
some accounting discrepancy or something,
but he was great.
He was a comedian and he ran the place and he developed like a lot of local
comedians were coming there too.
They had a nice local scene.
I think they still do.
Yeah,
I think they do.
Yeah.
It's probably the only one of the few local scenes in San Diego,
another club in nuclear cell phone when you had to be a winner.
The American comedy company.
So is that what it is?
I think I heard good things.
Yeah.
I haven't heard any of that.
San Diego's needed a real comedy club for a while.
Yeah.
Every time I go I do like house of blues or something like that.
I think the comedy,
sir,
it's a good room.
The hall.
It's a great book,
but it's not in San Diego.
Yeah,
it's,
well it's,
it's close enough.
You know what I mean?
But you know,
the problem is it's the comedy store and I can't work there.
Right,
man,
you fucked up.
You fucked up Rogan.
Yeah.
Get the fuck Outta here.
You can.
I'm here to tell you you still can't work then.
I probably could if I wanted to work there.
I tell you what.
I think we should just get,
get drunk and then one night just pop in there out of the blue.
What?
Do you want to go check on the or do you want to go to jail?
They will let you in.
Yeah.
I don't think so.
I'm not even interested.
It's zero desire,
but thank you very much.
That place where the names on the,
on the market at the laugh factory.
Right,
right next to me.
Jail.
Laugh factory.
No,
no,
no.
You're not Jimmy Brogan.
Somebody sent me a picture of your name and my name were the laugh factor.
No,
I don't have a show scheduled there.
I don't think it would've been there in over a decade since I've known you.
I haven't been there in over a decade,
you know,
not that it's bad club.
No,
I'm just trying to think why they to,
I stopped going to the laugh factory when it got serious at the comedy store
when I was like,
you know,
regularly at the comedy store,
Mitzi Aspen and not go there anymore.
So I don't forget,
I wasn't,
Mitzi was Scott Day actually I tell you about this house,
Sam triple,
he started doing the nightly show at the comedy store and it started getting
kind of popular and what's his face from at the laugh factory?
Started getting the comedy,
doing the naughty show also.
And he's his,
his uh,
sustain went to him.
He's like,
what?
Why he calls it the noughties.
Yeah.
And he's like,
why are you doing?
He's like,
oh,
I used to do naughty show in the 80s.
And I'm like,
yeah,
but you're only brought it back because we just started it back up here.
Brogan.
Sorry.
Back Up.
So what you're saying is the dude is doing another podcast that's doing another
comedy show with strippers and everything like that.
Did 90 show and it's its doors down from the comedy store where Sam now does it.
Well,
I want to be honest with Ya.
I think that's a terrible name.
And I think it only serves Sam,
right?
That he picked such a stupid name for a show.
Right.
What it really should do is use this opportunity to go with something,
something that doesn't suck and that way some guy can't just [inaudible].
I think he should call it sex squad Warren.
The show is a fun show to go do.
But that's a terrible God damn name.
Well,
it's just kind of basic,
so nothing,
it means nothing.
It's just be called naughty.
Like the Sam trip happy party.
Yeah.
Something like Sam triple e should be using one of the blowup himself,
not the naughty show.
Sam Tripoli's House of fun.
That would be just as good.
And by the way,
still use the same mailing list.
Dude.
We'll promote it.
All right,
Sam,
we're going to help you out of this mess.
Fuck Jamie Masada.
Let them have that shit by the,
I was doing it in the 80s.
That's probably what he said to you,
Bobby.
I had,
I had not the show in the eighties.
Let them have it,
dude.
Just like you should've let those girls have sex squad.
Let them have,
let them have it.
It sucks.
I think he'll,
I think he thought it'd be one choke on it.
Let them
go that they could never have had it without you.
How about that?
The scrum cap is the name of that thing I was trying to describe.
Oh,
I know what you're talking about.
A rugby.
Yeah.
I wear one of those Jujitsu.
It's got a little pads on it.
Yeah,
but it's mostly a cover my ears.
Yes.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
you die in that those fucking giant dudes a smash,
but not if you're not,
if they're not wearing play,
we going not going to get people to adjust.
You're going to have to have a raise,
a whole new generation.
They're going to have to have helmeted non helmeted but then there's going to be
the one thickheaded dude like some big Samoan guy who just wants a headbutt
people.
Why are you throwing me under the bus about this sex but I'm not throwing you
under the bus.
You wanted to do the first episode you told me to do it.
I think you should have no negative feelings out there and I think I agree with
that.
It's this girls look for whatever reason she's got a lot of issues.
I just think that that could have been avoided and you could have come off like
a a bigger person.
That's all I'm saying but but you're absolutely right.
Listen Brian,
you're not,
you're not being honest about that.
No.
You said I hate you.
I'll do your new show.
You said you need to do one asap and I'll be the first person on and I was like,
okay,
you know what that was before I found out the other girl came up with the name.
No,
I told you that too.
I have is the first one that told you that?
No,
no,
no.
You told me later.
You told me late.
Absolutely told me later cause it was cause I had to give you a wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
That girl,
wait a minute.
I told you that the first time that you might've thought you did,
but you did.
No,
I did Brian.
Cause I'd never not said I didn't come up with a name.
You can call me a liar when he saying Joe,
poor social skills here,
there's many way Asian.
That's not to call back tonight.
Ice has chronicles starts at eight 30 or being a silly person.
Okay.
I think you should let those girls have that name.
And I told him what the better.
Nah,
they right now they want to live in the hell of their own consciousness.
If they're angry at you.
That's right.
You don't want that buddy.
You don't want her out there with a Voodoo doll because she'd be putting the
pins.
You want to talk about them ever again.
She give her a big hug.
What would,
what would be a better name than sex squad?
Neil,
you're a creative guy.
You were the cocreator Chappelle show
podcast with hot chicks.
And what'd you,
what'd you call it?
I think he's got a,
I like the squad angle because it's death squad and it's about sex and it's a
podcast about sex.
I know.
Let's talk.
Let's talk about [inaudible].
No,
no.
Hmm.
How about the,
we like cock patrol.
Yeah.
That I'm with.
No,
no.
Are you still there?
Hmm.
It's funny that so many podcasts are going to try to try to lean in on that porn
angle though,
isn't it?
It's interesting.
It's like a natural angle mean we've,
we've had porn.
It's a,
it's hard to have a bad,
we had Sasha grey on,
she's with a black dude.
Uh,
and uh,
it,
it's fucking interesting.
She's fascinating cause she's actually smart.
Dina del Monte smart too.
She's crazy.
But she's fun.
She's very smart.
We had her on,
yes.
Sasha is like a regular cool check.
Yeah.
Isn't that weird?
Regular cool chick that somehow or another is missing this fuse where she can
just go take it in the ass
in front of the world.
What's weird is it's the oldest formula and radio it having a porn star on on a
show,
you know as like a guest like Howard Stern,
you know opie and Anthony,
any kind of local radio station will always have a porn star on,
but that was even before you actually got to see it,
which is crazy.
So now you've got like Ustream we're doing,
they get the naughty show we had the other day we had full on nudity.
I had to take it off.
You use stream because it was just ridiculous.
[inaudible] would they do,
which is trying to get you arrested by the way,
you might get arrested for shit like that.
You have to really be careful.
I know when you get those crazy bitches and they started fingering each other,
you can go to jail for that.
Fuck you.
You can't just PR like broadcast pornography.
Hello?
Yeah.
You get first of all stream,
we'll pull you because they don't want to get sued.
But if someone finds out that you're like project,
like if they find out that there's any sort of significant percentage of people
on Ustream that are showing people fucking,
oh well,
gosh,
here's a question,
because they actually weren't really too much of the nitty gritty,
but they took these stickers and put it on their boobs and then they did a whole
podcast with the stickers on a boot.
But you think that's fine.
That's fine.
That's one of those weird double standard thing.
Boob made is fine.
It is fine.
But you've got to,
yeah,
and I think you only need a couple of cover the,
the point of the nipple.
I think you could show some show area,
like if you have a star over the nipple itself,
but the circle of the aerial behind the star,
it's very clear.
I think it's still okay.
See,
so nuts were so crazy.
Human beings are so bizarre.
Excuse me.
American American,
when it comes to sex,
we're so nuts.
The way you could put a star over the nibble.
Well.
How about even this,
how about girls who were allowed to wear body paint?
They're fucking naked.
Naked.
It's okay.
I wonder if you could put a nipple sticker on top of a nipple.
Do you know what I mean?
Like a sticker with a picture of a nipple on it.
If that was with like an ape nipple.
I saw a photo from a friend of mine,
his Halloween party that he had a few years back with a bunch of girls came over
with body paint on and like one girl's tits were dogs look made up.
But,
but there were tits.
Tits would paint on them.
Yeah.
And it was an every girl knew it and all the,
he said girls that were there that were dressed in white,
all,
we're so fucking pissed.
They were so angry.
They were like,
who are these fucking whores?
Like we don't know that you're naked.
You stupid bitch.
And he'd get fucking paint on your tent and you think that that's okay.
Being shown up.
It was amazing.
What about [inaudible] have you ever went to,
what about Mannequin Nipples?
Cause now I've got those mannequins and they all have to be,
those are totally kosher.
Yeah.
It's not even real.
It's like,
you know,
animated.
If you drew an animated nipple,
who's,
Oh fuck,
what are you going to say?
Nobody could say anything.
I don't think.
I don't think that even counts as pornography.
It's definitely not mannequins,
man mannequins.
It sounded like a sex toy.
Like if you have like a real dog in the background and you could see the real
dolls tit,
that's probably,
that's tricky.
But not a mannequin.
Right?
Yeah.
But even the fact that it's like,
I actually asked this to a bunch of a female audience one time.
Like if they were robots,
like good
robots in the future and you,
you caught your husband fucking a robot,
would you be mad?
Right.
And they were like,
yeah.
And I was like,
but what if it looked like if it was like a real doll?
what if it looked like the terminator?
Right.
They had no problem with it.
Yeah.
I think it's just an ugly robot.
Well that's why people are weirded out.
If you fuck a fleshlight but they're not weirded out if you masturbate,
but fuck something,
a physical object.
It has to be like awesome.
It'd be the fake pussy in a tube.
Like what is that?
Well,
what are you doing?
What if the future that you had a robot that looked exactly like yourself but
that you fucked?
I agree.
[inaudible]
my sexuality on the rest of the world and I don't want to treat women as
objects,
so I would never have a fake woman.
So in having a fake me,
essentially what I'm doing is I'm taking the hit,
I'm taking the hit myself with a vagina and a,
I'm just knowing that if I was in jail with me,
I'd be a bro and let you fuck me.
I mean,
it's so weird seeing yourself.
I love kissing yourself.
Move your fake robot.
I was like an awesome tongue.
It's like,
Oh,
I love kissing you.
You're pushing your own head down.
You shoved her.
Yeah.
All right.
I'll suck your dick and your robot.
Oh,
it's me,
bro.
It's me.
It's me,
dude.
How do you like it?
I know how you like it.
I'm you.
Uh,
all right.
On that note,
Brian,
I'm sorry if you feel like a three or under the bus for the sock squad thing,
I didn't mean to buddy.
I don't want you to have any hard feelings.
I'm just trying to eliminate negativity in all of our lives.
I hear your brother and that's why I did.
I've never had a bad time with either one of those girls.
I've always had fun with them.
They were always nice to me.
So I hate to see something that I think could have been possibly avoided by just
a nice phone call.
Right?
Yeah.
Hey Man,
I don't know what the fuck happens for real.
I just,
there's no need.
There's a lot of real beef out there in this world is a lot of real drama.
Y'all need to unnecessary whites.
Word.
All right,
you fucking dirty freaks.
That's the end of this week.
This whole week of podcasts,
Fort Lauderdale Improv this weekend with Duncan Trussell.
Thursday,
Friday.
No,
Friday,
Saturday,
Sunday.
And then we'll be back next week with at least one podcast,
but next week I'm filming my special in Atlanta.
Congrats man.
Thank you.
Um,
the Tabernacle on Friday,
so I'm going to be concentrated on that almost more than anything and that's it.
All right.
Love you guys.
See you soon.
Bye.
Did you do the commercial?
Oh yeah.
Oh,
I got to do commercials.
Oh yeah.
On a.com.
As a new,
we have a,
a new thing for the next 34,
sorry,
30 something hours.
It's a,
the,
the Promo Code is crave and you get 21% off.
Um,
go to,
uh,
thanks to the flashlight and go to a fleshlight.com.
Enter in Rogan,
get 10% off and a on it.com is a,
also codeword Rogan.
And you get no flashlight.
You 15% on it,
you get 10.
But forget that Rogan code.
Use the Crave Code and you get 21% off.
Boom there.
That's it.
You dirty freaks.
We'll see you tonight.
The Ice House.
See this weekend,
the Fort Lauderdale.
See you next week,
some strange [inaudible] podcast and then the tabernacle jihad to you all.